cryptocurrency take it away patrick i have a not so fun topic well i guess it's interesting but i want to talk a little i was mentioning to jason uh sort of consumerism this idea that uh i mean it means lots of things but to me just the fact that you tend to want to buy things which don't last and then you you have to like kind of keep buying for various reasons and being in the in the tech industry i think this hits a lot that we keep hearing about the new phones that come out every month every week and it in the in the tech industry i think this hits a lot that we keep hearing about the new phones that come out every month every week and it seems like all the time and it's always oh now my phone is outdated i could buy this one that's a little bit better but if that's your criteria you sort of always have to keep buying new phones and new phones and you
加密货币，帕特里克，你来开个头吧。我有个不太有趣的话题，嗯，我想这挺有意思的，但我还是想聊聊。我刚才跟杰森提到了消费主义，这个概念意味着很多东西，但对我来说，就是你总是倾向于购买那些不耐用的东西，然后因为各种原因你不得不一直买。身处科技行业，我觉得这一点感触很深，我们总是听到每个月、每周都有新手机发布，好像永远都在出新款，然后总是觉得“哦，我的手机过时了，我可以买那个稍微好一点的”，但如果这是你的标准，你就得一直买新手机，一直买，你
know always upgrading your stuff and and of course you know like we use a lot of our technology to do our work you know having a laptop having a computer sort of necessary to doing work so some of that's understandable but as sort of a um just in general i try to be somewhat frugally minded in order to conserve the money that i i get for doing my work by not spending all of it um yeah i look at it yeah go ahead the same way i mean i look at money as as uh as as work so it's like you know is this new phone going to be worth you know x amount of hours of work and like if you think about it in that way it's often you know like not necessary to get the very latest phone if you have the second latest yeah so so that's one way i've heard described which actually there's
知道，总是要升级你的设备。当然，我们用很多科技产品来工作，比如笔记本电脑、电脑，这些是工作必需的，所以有些是可以理解的。但总的来说，我尽量保持节俭，为了省下我辛苦赚来的钱，不把它们全部花掉。是的，我明白你的意思，请继续。我也是这么看的，我把钱看作是劳动成果，所以我会想：这台新手机值得我花这么多小时去工作吗？如果你这么想，通常就不需要买最新的手机，买次新的就行了。是的，这就是我听说过的一种描述方式，其实有
several apps i know of where you can sort of calculate based on how much you expect to make this year, what your sort of hourly rate is. If you're paid hourly, it's, of course, easy. But if you're not paid hourly, you can sort of figure out what your hourly rate is and actually see sort of how many hours of work this is yeah the other part of it is and and maybe this is i don't know if this is good or bad but i actually use the the hourly rate of my first job like my first real job and i haven't really changed from that so that way it's like you know as if i get any raises or anything um that like hopefully i can save that or that that tends to get eaten up by like family things that you can't really control.
很多应用程序可以根据你今年的预期收入来计算你的时薪。如果你是按小时计薪的，那当然很容易。但如果你不是按小时计薪的，你可以算一下你的时薪，看看这东西到底需要你工作多少小时。是的，还有一点，我不知道这算好还是坏，但我实际上是用我第一份工作的时薪来计算的，而且我一直没改过。这样的话，如果我涨工资了，我希望可以把那部分存起来，或者那部分钱往往会被一些无法控制的家庭开支给花掉。
So, so how much, yeah. How long you'd have to work to earn this thing? I mean, I guess I had a pretty low paying first job, so that might be really depressing. Um, for, for some things I thought, well, I guess, I mean, your first full-time job. Oh, first full-time job. Okay. All right. Oh yeah.
所以，你需要工作多久才能买得起这个东西？我想我的第一份工作薪水挺低的，所以算起来可能会很沮丧。嗯，对于某些事情，我想，嗯，我是指你的第一份全职工作。哦，第一份全职工作。好的，明白了。哦，是的。
I don't count like, you know, in high school I, you you know sold popcorn or something yeah i don't really count that okay okay okay i was gonna say that's gonna be pretty bad um so another way of doing that i've heard someone describe which this is i guess a slightly nerdy way is if you talked about putting how much money would you have to put aside as like a sort of, you could talk about like an annuity or an investment. Like if you say the stock market returns on average 7% as like a gross simplification of this guy's scheme. If you say the stock market on average returns 7%, if you wanted to put enough money away
我不算那种高中时卖爆米花之类的工作，我不把那个算进去。好的，好的，我本来想说那算起来会很糟糕。嗯，还有另一种我听别人描述过的方法，这可能有点书呆子气，就是如果你谈论要把多少钱存起来作为一种年金或投资。比如，如果你说股市平均回报率为7%，这是对这个方案的粗略简化。如果你说股市平均回报率为7%，如果你想存足够的钱
so that you didn't use the capital for a purchase, but just the interest, how big would it need to be relative to how long you'll use the item? So if you say, I'm going to buy a car and I expect to drive my car five years, then in a car costs $10,000, how much money would you have to put away so that you would earn $10,000 over five years off of that investment? Oh, I see like passive income. Like what would you have to do to get $10,000 of passive income?
这样你就不用动用本金来购买，只用利息，那么相对于你使用该物品的时间，这笔钱需要有多少？所以如果你说，我要买一辆车，我打算开五年，车价是一万美元，你需要存多少钱才能在五年内从投资中赚到一万美元？哦，我明白了，就像被动收入。就像你需要做什么才能获得一万美元的被动收入？
That's right. So if you put, you know, $100,000 and earn 5% on it, I'm simplifying the numbers just to make them easier. Then you're saying that's $5,000 a year. So if I put $100,000 in an account that earned 5%, then I could use that money to buy something that costs $5,000 once a year. That makes sense. And if you could get all of your expenses in passive income, then you don't have to work anymore. Bingo. That's part of it. Yes. So for people who don't know, passive income means like a
没错。所以如果你投入十万美元，获得5%的收益，我简化了数字以便计算。那么你每年就有五千美元。所以如果我把十万美元存入一个收益率为5%的账户，我就可以用这笔钱每年买一件价值五千美元的东西。这说得通。如果你能通过被动收入覆盖所有开支，那你就不必再工作了。宾果。这就是其中的一部分。是的。所以对于不知道的人来说，被动收入意味着像
active income is your, is your W-2. Like, you know, in high school I went, I sold popcorn and at the end of the day I got a paycheck for that work. Sorry, we have foreign people. They won't know what a W-2 is. Oh, yeah, yeah. Sorry. Like, it means you actively went out and you did a job and you got a salary and your boss or somebody paid you for that work, right? Passive income is, I mean, it's really, it's investing, but it's more than that.
主动收入就是你的W-2工资。比如，高中时我去卖爆米花，一天结束时我因为那份工作拿到了一张工资支票。抱歉，我们有外国听众，他们可能不知道什么是W-2。哦，是的，抱歉。意思是你是主动去工作，拿到了薪水，你的老板或某人为你那份工作付了钱，对吧？被动收入，我的意思是，它确实是投资，但不仅仅是这样。
Basically, any way where you can put in money and take out more money without doing any work beyond just- Well, it's something that doesn't take your active attention. So like if you made a website that earned advertising revenue, you put in, it isn't really earning active income because you worked on it, but the amount you make isn't really per se related
基本上，任何你可以投入资金并取出更多资金，而无需做任何额外工作的方式——嗯，它是不需要你主动关注的东西。比如你做了一个赚取广告收入的网站，你投入了时间，这并不完全是主动收入，因为你确实为此工作过，但你赚的钱并不直接与
to how much work you put into it's it's sort of earning it passively yeah that's a good point there's a lot of ways to sort of think about that you see you earn for you could earn for many many years off of some website article that you wrote um even though you only spent you know a couple hours working on it and if that ratio is pretty good like if you spent you know a thousand hours working on it and earned only a few pennies over the lifetime, obviously that's still passive income, but it was not a very good return on your investment. Right. Yeah, that makes sense. Okay. So that's the second way of looking at is sort of this passive income sort of like investment strategy so that you get all your expenses covered. So like Jason said, you don't have to actively work anymore that would be awesome but that's also pretty scary because you for expensive things you pretty quickly figure out
你投入的工作量挂钩，它是被动赚取的。是的，这很有道理。有很多方法可以思考这个问题。你可以通过你写的一篇网站文章赚取很多年的钱，即使你只花了几个小时去写它。如果那个比例相当不错，比如你花了一千个小时去写它，但一生中只赚了几分钱，显然那仍然是被动收入，但投资回报率并不高。没错。是的，这很有道理。好的，这是第二种看待方式，即被动收入投资策略，这样你就能覆盖所有开支。就像杰森说的，你不需要再主动工作了，那会很棒，但也挺可怕的，因为对于昂贵的东西，你很快就会发现
you need sort of a large amount of money saved up to afford it yeah um then the other sort of way that i was just talking to jason about this before the the show is i ran across an article many years ago unfortunately the the original article hasn't actually been updated because it's become even worse. But it says it had a list of all of the Apple products up until that date, their initial price, and then what would you have in value of Apple stock if you had bought that many dollars of Apple stock instead of that item?
你需要存一大笔钱才能买得起。是的，嗯，还有另一种我刚才在节目开始前和杰森聊过的方式，我多年前偶然看到一篇文章，遗憾的是那篇文章没有更新，因为情况变得更糟了。但它列出了截至当时所有的苹果产品、它们的初始价格，以及如果你把买那些东西的钱换成苹果股票，你现在会拥有多少价值。
So, you know, the example here I found that's updated is if you bought the first iPod, which came out in 2001. So for some of you, you'd be like, oh, that was forever ago, but some of us remember that. In 2001, if you bought the first iPod, it cost $400 at the time. But now if you had bought $400 of Apple stock at that time instead of the iPod,
所以，我找到的这个更新后的例子是，如果你买了2001年发布的第一代iPod。对有些人来说，你会觉得那是很久以前的事了，但我们有些人还记得。在2001年，如果你买了第一代iPod，当时花了400美元。但如果你当时用这400美元买了苹果股票，而不是买iPod，
you would have had basically $39,000, almost $40,000. Keep in mind, I mean, it's a bit of survivor bias. Yes, no, there's a ton of survivor bias. Like if you had bought the Motorola stock for the Motorola Zoom instead of the iPod, then you would have, I don't know, probably close to nothing. Well, the one I use is, I used to have this,
你现在基本上会有3.9万美元，将近4万美元。请记住，这有点幸存者偏差。是的，确实有大量的幸存者偏差。比如如果你当时买了摩托罗拉Zoom的股票而不是iPod，那你现在可能一分钱都不剩了。嗯，我用的是，我以前有这个，
I don't even know if the brand's around, Rio, Rio MP3 player. Oh yeah, I remember that. So I bought like this, it used to be pretty popular, all these Rio MP3 players. If you bought Rio stock, it'd be worthless. But at least you would rio mp3 player oh yeah i remember that i bought like this there used to be pretty popular these rio mp3 players we bought rio stock it'd be worthless but at least you would have had an mp3 player instead it's absolutely survivorship bias totally but yeah just kind of an interesting but yeah even if you bought like an index or something um you know you would be you'd probably double your money by now uh depends on when in 2001 for that specific instance. That's a really good point.
我甚至不知道这个品牌还在不在，Rio，Rio MP3播放器。哦，是的，我记得。我买过这个，它曾经很受欢迎，所有这些Rio MP3播放器。如果你买了Rio的股票，它现在一文不值。但至少你当时有一个MP3播放器。这绝对是幸存者偏差，完全是。但这是一个有趣的例子。但即使你买了指数基金之类的，你现在的钱也可能翻倍了，具体取决于2001年买入的时间点。这确实是个好观点。
But in general, I mean, this is just saying if you buy the consumerism topic, you know, you buy an iPod, you buy an iPhone, you buy an iPad, you buy an Android phone and you use them for only a couple, three years. And then you might sell them to somebody else and you get a little bit back. But I mean, they're mostly worthless after that versus if you sort of, you know, save up that money or invest it, you know, it sort of is continuing to earn and becomes worth more and more. Um, interesting ways of sort of, I tried to limit because I think, I think our culture, well, some people say sort of, it's important for our culture to have people
但总的来说，这只是说如果你陷入消费主义，你买iPod、iPhone、iPad、安卓手机，只用两三年。然后你可能会把它们卖给别人，拿回一点钱。但我的意思是，在那之后它们基本上一文不值，而如果你把钱存起来或投资，它会持续增值，变得越来越值钱。嗯，我尝试限制消费，因为我认为我们的文化，有些人说我们的文化需要人们
spend a lot of money. That's how the economy grows. But as an individual, it's also very dangerous because this isn't, this is like some PSA or something, as an individual, it's also very dangerous because this isn't like some PSA or something. But, you know, it's also very dangerous to spend a lot of money, right? Spending money you don't have, you know, being forced to have to continue to work for more years than you would like to because you spent instead of saved. And those things didn't last. Yeah, exactly. I mean, I mean, it's there's a bit of a tragedy of the commons, right? Like if if everyone starts becoming frugal, I mean, basically, you know, if you bought stock in Apple, Apple went up. Why did Apple go up? Because people because other people bought iPhones. Yeah. And why did the stock keep going up? Because people kept buying iPhones like like the stock wouldn't have kept going up after 2007 or 2008 if everyone had just stuck with the first iPhone for three or four years. So it's sort of like, you know, you need people to keep buying things so that you can profit on your investments.
花很多钱，这样经济才会增长。但作为个人，这也是非常危险的，因为这就像某种公益广告一样。但是，花很多钱也是非常危险的，对吧？花你没有的钱，被迫比你想要的年限工作更久，因为你把钱花掉了而不是存起来。而且那些东西并不耐用。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，这有点像公地悲剧，对吧？如果每个人都开始变得节俭，基本上，如果你买了苹果的股票，苹果股价上涨了。为什么上涨？因为其他人买了iPhone。为什么股价一直涨？因为人们一直在买iPhone，如果每个人都坚持用第一代iPhone三四年，股价在2007或2008年后就不会一直涨了。所以你需要人们不断买东西，这样你才能从投资中获利。
But as an individual, like you don't want to get caught up in it yourself, so to speak. One thing I found kind of interesting is the cost of living across countries. And even for just bare essentials, the cost varies just enormously. And I found this thing called the Purchasing Power Parity Index, the PPP. And it'll show you, you know, for basic, you know, milk and all sorts of other things, how much those things cost in other countries, right? And it just kind of boggles my mind, like, why there's such an enormous difference. Like, why should, you know, milk or water or just simple, like, rice cost just, like, 10 times as much in one country than another um i mean i talked to someone at work about this and they were saying things like oh you have to ship it or or you have to grow it
但作为个人，你不想让自己陷入其中。我发现一件有趣的事是各国的生活成本。即使是基本必需品，成本差异也巨大。我发现了这个叫购买力平价指数（PPP）的东西。它会向你展示，对于基本的牛奶和其他各种东西，在其他国家的价格是多少，对吧？这让我感到困惑，为什么会有这么大的差异。为什么牛奶、水或大米在某些国家的价格是其他国家的十倍？
and the land is more expensive and the labor is more expensive and and i can kind of see it but but uh it still kind of boggles my mind like i still um i still don't understand why you couldn't just ship just a ton of rice from a place where it's cheaper to grow and ship it to the U.S. And, like, I don't really understand where the 10x comes from. But does it include things like taxes and tariffs? I'm sure it does, right? Because it's what the consumer pays, so it includes everything. But, yeah, I mean, maybe that's the answer.
我跟同事聊过这个，他们说是因为运输、种植、土地成本和劳动力成本更高，我能理解一点，但它仍然让我感到困惑。我不明白为什么不能直接从种植成本更低的地方运一大批大米到美国。我不明白这十倍的差价是怎么来的。但这是否包括税收和关税？肯定包括，对吧？因为这是消费者支付的价格，所以它包含了所有东西。但也许这就是答案。
I mean, I'm under the impression that there aren't really a lot of tariffs on on food and there's and food isn't taxed at least i don't think so um like when you go to the grocery store you don't pay taxes at least well i mean i don't know like in europe like do you pay like the vat tax even on like food and stuff i don't know yeah i don't know either i know in the u.s you don't but but either way it's like you know 10 times as much it just doesn't really make any sense um and uh yeah i just it's one of these things that kind of always boggles my mind because you know we hear a lot about people saying uh like outsourcing right like like people are gonna do work in this other country because it's cheaper, right? And, I mean, obviously some of that is maybe there's, like, certain luxuries that people have in one country and not another.
我的印象是，食品关税并不多，而且食品不征税，至少我不这么认为。比如你去杂货店，你不付税，至少在某些地方。我不知道，比如在欧洲，即使是食品也要付增值税吗？我不知道。我也不知道。我知道在美国不用，但无论如何，十倍的价格确实说不通。这总是让我感到困惑，因为我们经常听到人们说外包，因为在其他国家做工作更便宜，对吧？显然，有些是因为某些国家有某些奢侈品而其他国家没有。
But even just the basic staples of, like, just the basic food and things like that are just massively different across countries so somebody could potentially have like a more luxurious life with far less income in another country uh uh than they can in one country than they can in another and it just that part doesn't really make sense to me it seems like there need there would be some kind of arbitrage there well but for some stuff like food there's probably also regulation about testing and quality control and stuff. Right. So like you brought. Well, milk has like perishable problems.
但即使是基本的主食，在不同国家之间的价格差异也巨大。所以一个人在另一个国家可能用更少的收入就能过上更奢侈的生活。这部分对我来说真的说不通，似乎应该存在某种套利空间。嗯，但对于某些东西，比如食品，可能还有关于测试和质量控制的法规。没错。比如牛奶有易腐烂的问题。
But if you took something like rice, like it might be that the rice you find in one of these things, that's one tenth of what it is in another place. The quality control. Now, you may argue that it doesn't matter. Like you don't actually end up with a better product. But it might be that there are certain certificates required and testing to be done and all of that things adds costs. And that prevents someone from easily sort of taking the cheap rice in country a and just bringing it to country B because country B has essentially deliberately made that not possible in some way,
但如果你拿大米来说，可能在某些地方的价格是其他地方的十分之一。质量控制。你可能会争辩说这不重要，最终产品并没有更好。但可能需要某些证书和测试，所有这些都会增加成本。这阻止了人们轻易地从A国拿便宜的大米带到B国，因为B国在某种程度上故意让这变得不可能，
or else somebody would arbitrage it, right? Somebody would, if the transport costs and all that stuff lined up would take stuff from place a and sell in place b yeah that makes sense yeah it must be like regulation also there are things that i don't know if they even can be so for example um i have a lot of family in europe and they'll go to different countries for medical procedures right but in america that that doesn't happen like like
否则就会有人套利，对吧？如果运输成本等一切都对得上，就会有人从A地拿货卖到B地。是的，这说得通。一定是因为法规。还有一些东西，我不知道是否可以这样做。例如，我在欧洲有很多亲戚，他们会去不同的国家做医疗手术，但在美国这种情况不会发生。
if you need you know some kind of surgery you're not going to go shopping around at different countries and the reason why is because it's like so heavily regulated like you basically need to have you know your insurance subsidize your health care and they're not going to subsidize a procedure in another country and so so in this way it's kind of regulated i mean the legal system is also in the same way regulated right like there's and it's not it's not a malicious thing it's just the nature of it like there's a set of u.s laws that's different and so you can't just go to another country you can't outsource your like legal department um and so maybe these things just add like cause like the fact that you can't outsource your like legal department um and so maybe these things just add
如果你需要某种手术，你不会去不同的国家货比三家，原因是因为它受到严格监管。你基本上需要保险来补贴你的医疗保健，而他们不会补贴在另一个国家进行的手术。所以从这个角度看，它是受监管的。法律体系也是一样，对吧？这不是恶意的，只是它的本质。有一套不同的美国法律，所以你不能去另一个国家，你不能外包你的法律部门。所以也许这些事情增加了成本，因为你不能外包法律和医疗事务，这种成本会渗透到其他一切事物中。即使你经营一个稻田或进口大米，如果你的船员生病了，你必须支付高额费用。好吧，现在是新闻时间吗？引人深思。我觉得这些很有趣，但我没有好的答案。我的新闻没那么高深。
like cause like the fact that you can't really outsource legal and medical stuff that that cost percolates into everything else like even if you run a rice farm or even if you're a rice importer if someone in your ship gets sick or something you have to pay like an extraordinary fee or something all right well is it time for the news? Food for thought. I found this stuff interesting. I don't have any good answers. My news is way less high concept.
基本上，我不会讲太多细节。有个东西叫曼德博集合。它是一个递归方程。因为它是递归方程，你可以绘制这个方程，它是一个生成式方程，就像斐波那契数列一样，它在自身基础上构建。有人不断地构建它，调用它很多次，他们将曼德博集合放大了2的760次方倍。那是非常大的放大倍数。
It's basically, I won't go into a whole bunch of detail. There's this thing called a Mandelbrot set. It's a recursive equation. And because it's a recursive equation you can plot this equation and and it's a generative equation which means it's it's like the Fibonacci sequence right it builds on itself and somebody just kept building it and building it and calling it and calling it many times and they zoomed into the Mandelbrot set by a factor of 2 to the 760th power. That is a lot of zoom.
你可以观看大约10分钟，看着你进入这个曼德博集合，进入各种不同图案的漩涡。我觉得这很酷。是的，如果你以前从未见过分形、曼德博集合、朱利亚集合之类的东西，那是一个值得深入研究的兔子洞。但有趣的是，电影里那种“放大并增强”的场景在这里真的做不到，因为它是数学定义的，所以你只是不断地为任意精度的水平运行方程。然后你可以不断地深入，越来越小。
And you can literally watch for, I think it's 10 minutes, of just you entering this Mandelbrot set and just this vortex of different patterns. And I think it's kind of cool. Yeah, if you've never seen fractals in the Mandelbrot julius julia set stuff like that before like it's a rabbit hole to go down i guess um but it is pretty interesting that the sort of crime scene zoom in on this image and enhance you really can't do here because it's all mathematically defined so you just keep running the equation for sort of arbitrary levels of, I guess, precision. And then you can just keep going further and further and further, smaller and smaller things.
如果你尝试天真地做这些，你会遇到很多算术问题，比如稳定性，因为你开始处理非常小的数字。所以你必须非常小心地表示它们。是的，完全正确。你必须进行这种移位，所有的数字都是E的负200次方之类的。但你甚至不再存储那个了。你只是存储所有数字之间的相对关系。我只能猜测怎么做，但这超级有趣。看起来很有趣。哇，这个视频真的还在继续。
If you sort of try to do one of these naively, you run into a lot of problems with arithmetic, like stability, because you start getting into really tiny numbers. So you have to be very careful in how you represent them. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, you have to do this sort of shift where all your numbers are like, you know, E to the negative 200. But you're not even storing that anymore. You're just kind of storing all the numbers relative to each other. And yeah, I can only guess at how to do that. But it's super interesting. It's kind of fun to watch. Wow, this video really does just go on.
我现在正在看，我太分心了，这真的是10分钟的深入分形之旅。我见过那种移动视角的，但这个视频里他们甚至没有移动，只是在同一个位置放大，没有平移，就是直线放大。是的，太疯狂了。哦，有趣。好的，我要停下来了。好吧，10分钟后，我还要在这里待13分钟。我们最近做了一期关于代码审查的节目，谷歌测试博客上最近有一篇文章，说是来自他们的“厕所测试”系列，总结了代码健康，谈到了在发送代码审查之前可以采取的步骤。所以我们谈论了很多
And I'm watching it now i'm so distracted it's like legit it's 10 minutes of just diving into a fractal i've seen ones where they sort of move move it around but in this one they're not even moving it around they're zooming in on exactly the same like there's no translation it's just straight zoom yeah it's wild oh interesting okay i'm gonna stop this all right 10 minutes later i'm gonna be here for 13 minutes so we did a previous episode just recently on code reviews and there was a post recently on google's testing blog which uh says it came from their testing on the toilet episode um that they had to sum up code health and talking about steps that you can do before you send out a code review. So we talked about a lot
关于代码审查应该如何进行，为什么需要它。我看到网上在节目后有一些讨论，人们在谈论代码审查是否真的能改进代码。但我认为改进代码只是代码审查的一小部分目的。是的，捕捉Bug很好，但我不想说这是主要目的，但这绝对不是唯一目的。我几乎可以说，我得想一会儿，但同样重要的是，让别人熟悉你在做什么。拥有第二意见，与团队中的其他人互动，分享每个人在做什么。
of how code review should be done, why it should be there. And only part of it is actually to kind of, I saw some other sort of discussions where online after that episode where people were talking about, you know, does code review really improve your code? But I think actually improving your code is only one small aspect of what a code review is for. You know, yes, it's good to try to catch bugs, but that's not really, I don't want to say it's not the main purpose, but it is really not the only purpose. Almost, I would say, I'd have to think about it for a while. but close in importance is also the fact that you're getting someone else familiar with what you're doing. Uh, you know, having a second opinion, uh, just engaging with other people on your team, right. And sharing what everyone's up
以及允许人们之间轻松学习和指导。所有这些都是有用的目的。但谷歌博客提到，最好的审查可能是那些你不需要获得太多反馈，或者不需要多次迭代的审查。所以它给出了一些在开始之前要做的事情，以及在处理评论时要做的事情，
to and what they're working on. Um, and, and also allowing for easy sort of learning and mentorship between, between people. Um, all of those are useful purposes. But here, you know, the Google blog was talking about that the best reviews are probably the ones where you don't get a lot of feedback or you don't have to, you know, iterate through many times. And so I had a bunch of tips about things to do before you start and then things to do when you're sort of addressing comments
以防止事情失控。我觉得这很不错。我不会全部读出来，因为那样会很无聊。你可以自己去读那篇博客文章。但有几点，不要让审查太大。还有那些每个人都说应该做但并不总是做的事情，我尝试这样做，如果你的工具支持，先上传审查，自己先过一遍，确保没有遗漏明显的错误，比如留下了测试代码，或者有一个文件你改了一些东西但决定做点别的，却忘了撤销。那种事情。是的，对于不知道的人，“厕所测试”是这个东西，我想，我肯定其他公司也有，但我第一次听说是在谷歌。基本上，显然在他们的洗手间里，有关于如何成为更好的软件工程师的说明。所以当你坐在洗手间里时，你可以看它。给你提示。好的，有趣。
to prevent things from spiraling out of control. And I thought it was pretty good. I'm not gonna read all of them because they'd be kind of boring. You can just go read the blog post yourself. But a couple of them don't make it great. Yeah, don't make them too big. And then the ones that, you know, everyone probably says they should do, but doesn't always do, which is I tried to do sort of upload if your tool supports it, upload the
是的，审查提示。好的，我的第二个新闻是关于3D打印大规模生产的3D装箱问题。想法是，假设你有一个3D打印机，你想制作一堆小饰品，也许你想为所有的表亲制作一堆酷炫的玩具，但你想在一次打印任务中完成。你想设置好，去做别的事，12小时后回来，它已经打印好了10个，而不是打印一个，从机器上取下来，再打印另一个。所以这个人做了3D装箱并探索了有效的方法。对于不知道的人，
review and go through it yourself first and make sure you didn't miss any obvious things like leaving in test code or, um, you know, having a file where you were changing some stuff and decided to do something different and you forgot to revert it. Uh, you know, that kind of stuff. Yeah. For people who don't know, testing on the toilet is this thing that, um, I think, I mean, I'm sure other companies do it, but I first heard about it at Google, from Google. And basically, apparently in their bathrooms, they have instructions on how to be a better software engineer. So while you're sitting in the restroom, you can look at it. Giving you tips. Okay, interesting.
装箱问题是指你有一个特定的空间。想象一下2D装箱。你有一个正方形，然后你有一堆多边形，你需要尽可能多地把这些多边形塞进正方形里。有不同的目标。有些可能是多边形的数量。可能是你想尽可能多地消耗总面积。这就是装箱问题。这是一个NP完全问题，这意味着没有办法快速解决它。确保得到最佳答案的唯一方法是尝试每一种可能的排列，
Yeah. Reviewing tips. Yeah. Okay, so my my news is uh second news is 3d bin packing for 3d printer mass production so the idea is um let's say you uh have a 3d printer you want to make a bunch of little trinkets maybe you want to make a bunch of cool uh toys for all of your cousins um but you want to do it in one print job. You want to set it, you want to do something else, come back in 12 hours and have it be done with 10 of them instead of having to print one, take it off the machine, print another one. So this person did 3D bin packing and kind of explored that and ways to do that efficiently, right? And so for people
那太极端了，需要很长时间，永远也完成不了。所以有各种装箱算法可以给你一个近似的最佳解，只要不是退化情况。但没有保证。不过它们运行得很快。一个是模拟退火。模拟退火很简单。你从随机把东西放进盒子里开始。然后你开始交换。你说，好吧，把这块拿出来，看看能放什么进去。如果更好，就做。比如如果你能拿出一块，放进两块，那就做。
who don't know, bin packing is where you have a certain space. So imagine like 2D bin packing. So you have a square and then you have a bunch of things that are a bunch of polygons and you need to fit as many of these polygons as possible into the square. And there's different goals. Some might be the number of polygons. It might be you want the total area to be consumed as much as possible. And so that's the bin packing problem. And there's no, like, it's an NP complete problem, which means that there isn't a way to just do this fast right like like the only
但如果你拿出一块，却放不进任何东西，有时也要这样做。他们称之为温度项。所以有时你改变了方案，让它变得更糟。并且以一定的概率，你会接受那个更糟的方案。想法是，也许它会引导你找到更好的方案。所以随着时间的推移，你不断地取出东西，放回东西。当你这样做时，你降低温度，直到温度为零，你只在方案变好时才进行交换。这叫模拟退火。
way to do it uh to make sure you got the best answer um guaranteed is to literally try like every possible arrangement right um you know that is pretty extreme it's gonna take a long time it's never gonna finish so there's all sorts of bin packing algorithms that give you, you know, you know, approximately the best solution, as long as it's not some degenerate case. But there's no guarantee. But they run very fast. So one is simulated annealing. Simulated annealing is very simple. You start off by just randomly putting things in the box. And then you start swapping. You start off by just randomly putting things in the box and then you start swapping. You say, okay, take this piece out and see what I can put in its place. And if it's better, then do it. Like if you could take a piece out and put two in, then just do it, right?
这个人用3D实现了它。这很酷。你可以看到它找出不同的方式来排列物体，这样他可以在一次3D打印中打印出8个。所以，去看看吧，很酷。所有这些的问题在于我的3D打印机不够可靠，如果我尝试这样做，它很可能会在三分之一的时候搞砸，毁掉剩下的部分。哦，不，得买台新3D打印机。哦，那永远是解决方案。我们谈过这个，那是消费主义。哦，那是真的，你的坏了，所以我认为你还好。所以，我的第二个文章是一系列编程观察。我知道这不算什么，但我看到的那个很不错，因为专门关于我们播客的性质，我觉得很适用。
But if you could take a piece out and you can't put anything in its place, then sometimes do that anyways. Then they call this the temperature term. So sometimes you change the solution and you make it worse. And with some probability, you're going to take that worse solution. And the idea there is maybe it'll lead to anything better solution. And so over time, you're constantly taking things out, putting things back in. And as you do this, you're lowering taking things out, putting things back in. And as you do this, you're lowering the temperature to the point where the temperature is zero and you're only making a swap if it's better. That's called simulated annealing.
显然我今天处于一种非常喜欢给建议的模式。首先我谈了测试技巧和消费主义，总之，随便吧。这是今天的主题。引用这个网页的一句话：你花在学习新语言上写代码的每五分钟，都比花五小时阅读关于那门语言有多棒的博客文章更有用。好的，这很公平。我在Reddit上看到了这个。有人发了这个，我去了那个页面，
And this person implemented it in 3D. And it's kind of cool. You can actually see it figure out different ways to arrange objects objects so that he can print you know eight of them on it on one 3d print so yeah check it out it's pretty cool the problem with all that is my 3d printer isn't reliable enough that if i tried to do that it would likely mess up you know a third of the way through and just ruin the rest of it oh no gotta get a new 3d printer oh that's always the solution we talked about this that's consumer um oh that's true well yours is yours is broken so i think you're okay so um my second uh article is a series of programming observations i know it's not great but i the one i saw was was pretty good because specifically about the nature of our podcast I thought was applicable.
它还列出了一堆其他的东西，比如Perl出现在系统中的可能性与系统维护的时间长度成正比。不错。他们大概有10个这样的东西，我想这可能是一段时间以前的了，但我听到一个说法，链接到2007年的互联网档案馆，但大多数仍然适用。在假设CSV是一个简单易用的文件格式之前，请三思。是的，那是真的。对于不知道的人，比如如果你有一个逗号，一个引号，请继续。哦，我本来想说，如果你在引号里有一个引号，所以你知道在CSV中使用引号
And apparently I'm in a very advice-giving mode today. First I talked about testing tips and about consumerism and anyways, whatever. It's a thing today. a quote from this webpage that every five minutes you spend writing code in a new language is more useful than five hours of reading blog posts about how great that language is. Okay. That's fair. So I saw this on Reddit. Someone had posted this and I went to this page that,
当你字段里有逗号时，你想引用整个字段，这样逗号就不会弄乱文件的其余部分。但如果你在引用的字符串里有一个引号会怎样？结果你必须，我想是双引号，所以如果CSV解析器看到两个引号，它会将其解释为字面引号，这是一个非常糟糕的设计决定。它变成了一场彻底的噩梦。是的。节目书单时间。节目书单。我的节目书单是我在Audible上买的第一本书。
uh, also lists a bunch of these other things like the likelihood of Pearl being involved in a system is directly proportional to the length of time the system has been in maintenance. Nice. Uh, and it was, they just have a you know like probably like 10 of these things i guess this is a little probably from a little while ago but uh i hear a saying uh links to the way back machine 2007 but uh most of these are still applicable think twice before presuming that csv is a nice little easy file format to use yeah that's true yeah so for people don't know like if you have a comma a quote go ahead oh i was gonna say if you have a quote inside of a quote so so you know you use quotes in a csv
现在我一直在通勤时使用Audible。它叫《圆圈》。还不错。所以我感觉我有一种混合的评价。一方面，它开始时很棒。这本书的基本前提，不剧透的话，是这位女士加入了一家公司，公司非常进步，他们有各种酷炫的福利，有强大的公司文化，有羽毛球队、篮球队，有所有这些不同的
when you have let's say commas in the field and so you want to quote the whole field that way the commas don't mess up the rest of the file right but what happens if you have a quote inside of the quoted string it turns out you have to actually i think it's double quoted and so if if the csv you know parser sees two quotes it interprets as a literal quote and uh that is just a very bad design decision. It turns into a total nightmare. Yeah. Time for book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show is the first book I bought on Audible.
组织，感觉就像加入了一个大学校园，有很多事情可以做，有很多友好的人，各种不同的活动，免费食物等等。基本上她发现它正在接管她的生活，当她试图退后一点时，事情就开始变糟了。基本上，这是一本有趣的书。问题是，我觉得作者有点后劲不足。我想这是戴夫·艾格斯写的。我觉得他在书的一半时就没劲了。因为我真的很惊讶，因为我读到了一半，突然出现了一段性爱场景。这真的不太合适。
Now that I've been using Audible on my shuttle ride. So it's called The Circle. It was pretty good. So I felt as if i have kind of a mixed review um on one hand it started out amazing um the the basic premise of the book without spoiling anything is uh um this lady joins this company and and the company is very progressive and uh um they have all sorts of cool perks there's like a strong company culture there's like a you know badminton team a basketball team there's all these different
然后它似乎，我不知道，这让我感觉很不好。在那之后，这本书就变成了一本浪漫小说。一切都关于男朋友之类的。关于这家公司接管这个人的生活的整个主题还在，但就像有所有这些额外的填充物。所以读到结尾有点费劲。但这是一个伟大的故事，整体情节很棒。我跳过了几章，但我肯定会再读一遍，或者我会推荐给别人读。但要准备好，要经历一点泥泞的道路。但总的来说，这是一本好书。
organizations and it feels kind of like joining a college campus or something there's just so much to do there's a lot of friendly people there's all sorts of different activities free food all stuff um and uh and and basically what she finds is that it's sort of uh taking over her life and when she tries to pull back a bit um it things kind of go south and basically uh it's an interesting book um the thing is i feel as if the writer kind of ran out of steam. This is, I think, Dave Eggers. And I think he ran out of steam kind of halfway through the book because it actually like I was really surprised because I had gone halfway through the book. And then all of a sudden there was like a sex scene like described in the book. And it was just really like it didn't really fit at all.
是的，我以为只有我才会给出这种带有保留意见的推荐。我的意思是，如果你给出任何类型的评论，不是所有东西都会得到五星或一星，但我会说这是三到四星。是的，这很公平。所以我的书是我以前尝试听过、读过，但没读完的书。我放弃了，但我又回去读了，因为有太多人在网上向我推荐它。然后在工作中，有人告诉我他们认为这本书太棒了，然后另一个我甚至不知道喜欢科幻小说的人也插话说，哦，是的，这是一本非常好的书。
And then it just seemed like I don't know if like that just put a bad taste in my mouth. It seemed like after that, the book just turned into like a romance novel. Like it's just everything was about boyfriends and stuff like that. And the whole like thing about this company taking over this person's life was just kind of like it was still there. But it's almost like there's all this extra filler um so you know it's a little bit of slog to get through um to get to the ending um but uh it's a great story the overall plot is great um and i skipped like a couple of sections uh and with that i i would definitely read it again or i would you know advertise other people to read it but get ready for you know a little. But get ready for a little bit of mud to have to slog through. But overall, it was a good book.
与同事交流总是很有趣，你知道人们是什么样，但不一定知道他们的阅读品味，或者是否与你兼容。你必须根据人们进行校准，这听起来很奇怪，我不是指任何奇怪的事情，我只是说，人们喜欢不同类型的电影。有些书非常受欢迎，这其实很难。我知道Netflix在很久以前的一篇博客文章中谈到过，如果你看了一部受欢迎的电影，比如《指环王》，那并不意味着他们可以开始向你推荐另一部奇幻电影。
Yeah, I thought I was the only one who made these sort of like caveated recommendations. I mean, well, the thing is like it's sort of like if you give any type of review, you know, not everything is going to get five stars or one star but I would say this is like a three or four star yeah that's fair it's fair so mine is a book that I had actually tried to listen to before read before um and didn't make it through like started it just kind of gave up so I went back because i've had so many people sort of like online recommend this to me then at work actually somebody was telling me that they just think this thing's amazing this book was amazing and then actually someone else who i didn't even know was into sort
是啊，我以为只有我才会给出这种带有保留意见的推荐。我的意思是，好吧，问题在于，如果你给出任何类型的评价，你知道，并不是所有东西都会得到五星或一星，但我会说这大概是三星或四星，是的，这很公平，很公平。所以我推荐的这本书，其实我之前尝试过听，也尝试过读，嗯，但没读完，刚开始就放弃了。所以我又回去读了，因为有很多人在网上向我推荐这本书，然后在工作中，实际上有人告诉我，他们觉得这本书太棒了，简直太棒了，然后还有另一个人，我甚至不知道他喜欢那种
of science fiction was chipping in that oh yeah this is a really good book um and it's always interesting with co-workers you know like you know how people are but you don't necessarily know what their tastes and in books are or whether like sort of compatible with you like you have to sort of calibrate against people um which sounds really weird i don't mean that anything like weird i just mean that no i mean so people are into different types of movies yeah and some books are like very popular and it's actually really hard and i know that netflix talked about this in one of a blog post i read from there's whoever knows how long ago but that like if you watch a popular movie like the lord of the rings um that doesn't mean they can start recommending to you like another fantasy
科幻小说，也插话说，哦，是的，这是一本非常好的书。嗯，和同事相处总是很有趣，你知道，你知道人们是什么样的人，但你不一定知道他们的阅读品味，或者是否与你兼容，你必须根据人们来校准，这听起来很奇怪，我不是说任何奇怪的意思，我只是说，不，我的意思是人们喜欢不同类型的电影，是的，有些书非常受欢迎，这实际上真的很难，我知道Netflix在很久以前我读过的一篇博客文章中谈到了这一点，就是如果你看了一部受欢迎的电影，比如《指环王》，那并不意味着他们可以开始向你推荐另一部奇幻作品
movie because the lord of the rings was sort of like almost like a pop culture phenomenon yeah it was like had mass appeal but that doesn't mean that you're likely like, what do they recommend to you? They could recommend to other blockbusters. But and they will probably recommend to you some probability of other fantasy movies. But it's probably not a strong recommendation. Yeah, it's kind of like saying, you know, if someone says they like the Beatles, you don't start recommending a bunch of indie music. Yeah, yeah. I don't I don't know that much about the beatles but i'll just i'll just say
电影，因为《指环王》几乎是一种流行文化现象，是的，它具有大众吸引力，但这并不意味着你很可能会喜欢它，他们会向你推荐什么呢？他们可能会推荐其他大片。而且他们很可能会向你推荐一些其他奇幻电影的概率。但这可能不是一个强有力的推荐。是的，这就像是说，你知道，如果有人说他们喜欢披头士乐队，你不会开始推荐一堆独立音乐。是的，是的。我对披头士乐队了解不多，但我只是，我只是说
yes are kind of like michael jordan or something where everyone just likes the beetle oh okay okay yeah you can't learn much anyways so i don't think this is a super super popular book but it did win the hugo all right cut to the chase this is the three body problem um by a chinese author who i won't i won't uh attempt to pronounce the name because i'm terrible at such things um but the apparently this is a like the best-selling or at least one of the best-selling authors in china that it's a very very popular person there and this is not in chinese it's been translated um and the translation was really good other than the fact that um you know the sort of names are preserved as best i can tell and in sort of the english version of the chinese name um okay what i mean there is that it isn't that they gave
是的，有点像迈克尔·乔丹之类的，每个人都喜欢披头士，哦，好吧，好吧，是的，反正你也学不到什么，所以我不认为这是一本超级超级畅销的书，但它确实赢得了雨果奖，好了，言归正传，这就是《三体》，嗯，一位中国作家写的，我不会，我不会尝试去读他的名字，因为我不擅长这些事情，嗯，但是显然这是中国最畅销的，或者至少是最畅销的作家之一，他在那里是一个非常非常受欢迎的人，而且这不是中文写的，它是翻译过来的，嗯，而且翻译得非常好，除了这样一个事实，嗯，你知道，名字被保留了下来，据我所知，是以某种英文版的中文名字的形式，好吧，我的意思是，并不是说他们给了
them like alan and bob like they use the original chinese name oh got it and it's and it's large but it's written in english letters what is that called transcription transliteration that's something like that something like that yeah that's what you're saying um and it did it was a good read because i felt like it was sort of inherently different than most of the other science fiction i read which takes a sort of western view of things and so you sort of fall into even if it's different authors with their own unique ideas you sort of fall into these common tropes and common ways of acting and interacting with people. And so it was very nice to see something presented from a sort of different, it felt almost kind of a, it sounds bad,
他们像艾伦和鲍勃这样的名字，他们用的是原来的中文名字，哦，明白了，而且它很大，但它是用英文字母写的，那叫什么？转写，音译，差不多就是那样，差不多就是那样，是的，这就是你要说的，嗯，它确实是一本好书，因为我觉得它在本质上与我读过的大多数其他科幻小说不同，那些小说采取了一种西方视角，所以即使是不同的作者有他们自己独特的想法，你也会陷入这些常见的套路和与人互动的方式中。所以看到一些以某种不同的方式呈现的东西是非常好的，它感觉几乎是一种，这听起来很糟糕，
like a foreign view, something that isn't what I'm used to reading or what I'm used to experiencing. And it was nice to read a book that way, but it was still science fiction. It still had some of those same themes, but they were presented in sort of a fresh way. And so I thought that was an interesting read but i won't say that it was my like most favorite read ever um but it was
一种外国的视角，一些我不习惯阅读或不习惯体验的东西。以这种方式读一本书感觉很好，但它仍然是科幻小说。它仍然有一些相同的主题，但它们以一种新鲜的方式呈现出来。所以我认为这是一次有趣的阅读，但我不会说这是我最喜欢的阅读，嗯，但它
definitely and apparently there's i didn't so some people who i talked to didn't actually know there was more books to this but apparently it's a trilogy and this is the first book of a trilogy um and so i sort of expressed to to one of my co-workers who had read all of the trilogy like yeah you know i wasn't super enthused overall about it uh and he sort of said but this is kind of only the opening gambit that like the real meat of the story takes place in uh second and third books which i always find to be interesting for things which are trilogies which is they really do need to hook you in or you're not going to read the second book and so like what do you do after you read the first book do you say well i'm going to give it a fair shake and read the second and third books am i going to give it a fair shake and only read
绝对是，而且显然有，我没有，所以一些和我交谈过的人实际上并不知道还有更多的书，但显然这是一个三部曲，这是三部曲的第一本书，嗯，所以我向我的一位读过整个三部曲的同事表达了，就像，是的，你知道，我总体上并不是特别热衷于它，嗯，他有点说，但这只是开局，故事的真正精髓发生在第二和第三本书中，我总是觉得这对三部曲来说很有趣，那就是它们确实需要吸引你，否则你不会读第二本书，所以就像你读完第一本书后会做什么？你会说，好吧，我要给它一个公平的机会，读第二和第三本书吗？我会给它一个公平的机会，只读
the second book because then it's sort of unfortunate not to read the third you know like what do you do like i i probably wouldn't have actually i wouldn't have gone ahead and tried again reading it if i had known it was going to be a trilogy that sounds terrible because now i'm in this awkward position yeah i see i mean it sounds like yeah i mean it's really you really have to trust that person who told you to read the second one you know but they really recommended the first book but they recommended it in light of the whole trilogy but i didn't know i was signing up for a full trilogy commitment but they didn't tell me that it was only because, you know,
第二本书吗？因为那样的话，不读第三本有点可惜，你知道，就像你该怎么办？就像我，我可能不会，实际上我不会继续尝试再读一遍，如果我知道它会是一个三部曲的话，这听起来很糟糕，因为现在我处于这种尴尬的境地，是的，我明白，我的意思是，听起来，是的，我的意思是，你真的必须信任那个让你读第二本的人，你知道，但他们确实推荐了第一本书，但他们是在整个三部曲的背景下推荐的，但我不知道我是在签署一份完整的三部曲承诺，但他们没有告诉我，这只是因为，你知道，
your memory is sort of skewed. Like you remember the first book in light of what you learned in the second and third books. Yeah. You know, it's like when you rewatch the matrix movie, oh, this is a dated reference.
你的记忆有点扭曲。就像你根据在第二和第三本书中学到的东西来回忆第一本书一样。是的。你知道，这就像当你重看《黑客帝国》电影时，哦，这是一个过时的参考。
It's not the same as the first time you watch it. Yeah. Because yeah, you kind of have the whole context of a mental model of what's the. Yeah. So, okay. That was a sort of a side tangent, but the three body problem it you know it was definitely a fresh day it was something that was different for me um and i enjoyed the experience of you know trying something a little different to new i don't give it it's my my highest marks but i do i do think it was a good book cool that makes sense and you can read you can read both these mediocre books oh man well you know the
它和你第一次看的时候不一样。是的。因为是的，你对什么是，有了一种心理模型的完整背景。是的。所以，好吧。那是一个侧面的题外话，但《三体》，你知道，它绝对是一个新鲜的一天，它对我来说是不同的，嗯，我享受了尝试一些新东西的体验，我不会给它我最高的评价，但我确实认为这是一本好书，酷，这很有道理，你可以读，你可以读这两本平庸的书，哦，伙计，好吧，你知道
thing is we uh uh you know we always report the the books that we actually read i mean i actually saw recently a book that i thought was pretty cool um but i felt like i'm not gonna mention it because i haven't read it yet and uh um you know one thing that we try and do is is we try to read every single book that we recommend. And we're sort of doing that on Audible. So if you want to check out Audible, you can go to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown. If you don't want to go on Audible, you can still support the show by going to patreon.com slash programmingthrowdown. And we have links in the show notes and we definitely
事情是，我们，嗯，嗯，你知道，我们总是报告我们实际读过的书，我的意思是，我最近确实看到了一本我觉得很酷的书，嗯，但我感觉我不会提到它，因为我还没读过，而且，嗯，你知道，我们尝试做的一件事是，我们尝试阅读我们推荐的每一本书。我们正在 Audible 上做这件事。所以如果你想看看 Audible，你可以去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。如果你不想去 Audible，你仍然可以通过去 patreon.com/programmingthrowdown 来支持这个节目。我们在节目说明中有链接，我们绝对
appreciate um all of you for checking out audible and supporting us on pet on patreon and you can check out some of the other show notes for books we actually recommended maybe make those your first try yeah exactly um so my tool of the show is um as everyone knows i got a 3d printer and i've been super, super excited about that. I've been printing just unbelievable amounts of stuff. A lot of it is just cluttering, you know, our whole house. But some of it, the things that really went over the best were these screw puzzles. So for people who don't know, a screw puzzle is basically um if you remember these were really popular back in the day i don't know if they're still popular but remember that puzzle
感谢你们所有人查看 Audible 并支持我们的 Patreon，你可以查看一些其他节目说明，看看我们实际推荐的书籍，也许把它们作为你的第一次尝试，是的，完全正确，所以我的节目工具是，嗯，正如每个人都知道的，我买了一台 3D 打印机，我对此感到超级超级兴奋。我一直在打印数量惊人的东西。其中很多只是让我们的整个房子变得杂乱无章。但其中一些，真正最受欢迎的东西是这些螺丝拼图。所以对于不知道的人来说，螺丝拼图基本上是，嗯，如果你还记得这些在过去非常流行，我不知道它们现在是否还流行，但还记得那个拼图
where there are the horseshoes and the horseshoes have chain link connecting oh yeah yeah horseshoes to each other yeah and there's a ring in like going around the chain like a metal ring and the ring you know can't fit over each of either of the horseshoes to get out but if you bend the the horseshoes and the chain link in a certain way then you can actually you know create a surface that's narrow enough for the for the for the um for the ring to escape and so screw puzzles are basically that they're ways for you to sort of turn objects in a way where you can either separate them or put them together. I mean, they're both effectively the
那里有马蹄铁，马蹄铁有链环连接，哦，是的，是的，马蹄铁彼此连接，是的，有一个环像金属环一样绕着链条，你知道，环不能套在任何一个马蹄铁上拿出来，但如果你以某种方式弯曲马蹄铁和链环，那么你实际上可以，你知道，创造一个足够窄的表面，让环逃脱，所以螺丝拼图基本上就是这样，它们是你以某种方式转动物体的方法，你可以把它们分开或放在一起。我的意思是，它们实际上都是
inverse of each other. So they're both interesting. And so there's actually a Thingiverse blueprint for printing, I think, five screw puzzles. And they have different levels of difficulty. So the easiest is it's basically looks like a bagel but it's been cut in a certain way where you have to just screw the two pieces together to to you get these two pieces are just very oddly shaped and if you just kind of try to put them together like two halves of a bagel like it's just not going to look right but if you kind of screw them into each other and you can actually create a bagel like it looks just not gonna look right but if you kind of screw them into each other and you can actually create a bagel like it looks like a torus right um and they have a bunch like that
彼此的逆运算。所以它们都很有趣。所以实际上有一个 Thingiverse 蓝图可以打印，我想，五个螺丝拼图。它们有不同的难度级别。所以最简单的是，它基本上看起来像一个百吉饼，但它以某种方式被切割，你必须把两块拼在一起，直到你得到这两块形状非常奇怪的碎片，如果你只是尝试把它们像两个半个百吉饼一样放在一起，就像它看起来不会是对的，但如果你把它们拧在一起，你实际上可以创造一个百吉饼，就像它看起来不会是对的，但如果你把它们拧在一起，你实际上可以创造一个百吉饼，就像它看起来像一个圆环，对吧，嗯，它们有很多像那样的
they're super super fun the only thing uh um uh you know you have to sand it down um i actually cut my finger on one of them oh no yeah i know i mean not badly i mean it didn't even break the skin but it kind of like stings and it's right on my fingertip so it them oh no yeah i know i mean not badly i mean it didn't even break the skin but it kind of like stings and it's right on my fingertip so it like stings when i type cutting edge of science that's right uh this is super super entertaining especially after i sanded them down i was able to like you know give them to my family and let them try it out and stuff um so yeah if you have a if you have a 3d printer or I think on Thingiverse you can actually outsource it
它们超级超级有趣，唯一的事情，嗯，嗯，嗯，你知道，你必须把它打磨平，我实际上在其中一个上割伤了我的手指，哦，不，是的，我知道，我的意思是，并不严重，我的意思是，它甚至没有弄破皮肤，但它有点像刺痛，而且就在我的指尖上，所以它，哦，不，是的，我知道，我的意思是，并不严重，我的意思是，它甚至没有弄破皮肤，但它有点像刺痛，而且就在我的指尖上，所以它在我打字时会刺痛，科学的前沿，没错，嗯，这超级超级有趣，特别是在我把它们打磨平之后，我能够像，你知道，把它们给我的家人，让他们尝试一下之类的，嗯，所以是的，如果你有一台 3D 打印机，或者我想在 Thingiverse 上，你实际上可以外包它
to someone with a lower purchasing parity index or whatever you can through Thingiverse you can pay a certain fee and they'll actually print it for you or they'll figure out a way to print it for you and send it to you
给一个购买力平价指数较低的人，或者无论什么，你可以通过 Thingiverse 支付一定的费用，他们实际上会为你打印它，或者他们会想办法为你打印它并寄给你
so either way if you have your own printer or if you want to just go on there and pay someone to print it, I found them super fun. And I'm going to definitely get more of them. My tool to show, as usual, is, although you did just present a, like, printed object, but mine is weird. So mine is Inbox from Gmail. And I, you know, I know everybody knows about this,
所以无论哪种方式，如果你有自己的打印机，或者如果你想去那里付钱让人打印它，我发现它们超级有趣。我肯定会得到更多。我的节目工具，像往常一样，是，虽然你刚刚展示了一个，像，打印的物体，但我的很奇怪。所以我的是 Gmail 的 Inbox。而且我，你知道，我知道每个人都知道这个，
but I just wanted to, I guess, maybe rant a little bit for a second. But I still, I feel spoiled by how nice, I really resonate with the Inbox way of doing things. I don't know what it is. It works for me. It makes sense to me. I've also used the Gmail with tabs.
但我只是想，我想，也许抱怨一下。但我仍然，我感到被 Inbox 做事的方式宠坏了，我真的与 Inbox 的做事方式产生了共鸣。我不知道那是什么。它对我有效。它对我来说很有意义。我也用过带标签的 Gmail。
And I, you know. That's the mail.google.com, right? Yeah, I don't know. My mail.google.com, I think, redirects to Inbox now. But, you know that's uh the mail.google.com right yeah i don't know my mail.google.com i think redirects to inbox now but oh okay um you know i i really do like inbox i like the fact that i can sort of do the there used to be a another project uh called boomerang that you could use to do this in gmail but now inbox does it directly where you can sort of send an email message to go sort of archive itself and then come back to you in a certain amount of time. Um, I use it all the time for like, you know, Hey, I need this to come back,
而且我，你知道。那是 mail.google.com，对吧？是的，我不知道。我的 mail.google.com，我想，现在重定向到 Inbox 了。但是，你知道那是，嗯，mail.google.com，对吧，是的，我不知道，我的 mail.google.com，我想现在重定向到 Inbox 了，但是，哦，好吧，嗯，你知道，我，我真的很喜欢 Inbox，我喜欢这样一个事实，我可以，像，做那个，过去有另一个项目，嗯，叫 Boomerang，你可以在 Gmail 中使用它来做这个，但现在 Inbox 直接做到了，你可以，像，发送一封电子邮件，让它自己归档，然后在一定时间内回到你身边。嗯，我一直用它，像，你知道，嘿，我需要这个回来，
but not right now. So like, you know, get an email from, this is not true, but like, Oh, my credit card is due at the end of the month. Well, I don't want to know about it at the beginning of the month. So, you know, it's come back to me you know a two days before you're due um and then i can go online and pay this bill yeah whatever but i you know a couple things one is like people who are still using the old school gmail it's just like oh man no i feel like the inbox is so much nicer and the other thing is well i i know people like the way things are because they're the way things are but it's really frustrating for me to use other, like my work mail is just like, ah,
但不是现在。所以就像，你知道，收到一封电子邮件，来自，这不是真的，但就像，哦，我的信用卡在月底到期。好吧，我不想在月初知道它。所以，你知道，它在到期前两天回到我身边，嗯，然后我可以上网支付这笔账单，是的，无论如何，但我，你知道，有几件事，一件事是，像那些仍然在使用老派 Gmail 的人，这就像，哦，伙计，不，我觉得 Inbox 好多了，另一件事是，嗯，我知道人们喜欢事情的样子，因为它们就是那样，但对我来说，使用其他东西真的很令人沮丧，像我的工作邮件就像，啊，
I so much wish this would be more like inbox or, you know, whatever. Like it just feels so stuck in a dated way of doing things. Um, my only gripe with inbox is that they haven't implemented filters yet. So I actually have to go to regular. I do.
我非常希望这能更像 Inbox，或者，你知道，无论什么。就像它感觉被困在一种过时的做事方式中。嗯，我对 Inbox 的唯一抱怨是他们还没有实现过滤器。所以我实际上必须去常规的。我确实。
I will say I do do that. That's true. Man, you you're making me i'm like now i have to give a mediocre recommendation for my 12th month too four star one star just got knocked off it's like okay so i do balance and back off so i really do like the idea this is i'm not a show for google in some way they don't pay me for this google.com is amazing but i do like the fact that you it's it's like it's not like api compatible isn't the right word, but the paradigm in inbox is perfectly compatible with regular Gmail.
我会说我确实那样做了。那是真的。伙计，你让我，我现在不得不给我的第 12 个月也做一个平庸的推荐，四星，一颗星刚被扣掉，就像，好吧，所以我确实平衡并退后了，所以我真的很喜欢这个想法，这不是，我不是谷歌的托，他们不为此付钱给我，google.com 很棒，但我确实喜欢这样一个事实，你，它就像，它不像 API 兼容不是正确的词，但 Inbox 中的范式与常规 Gmail 是完全兼容的。
Like you can send messages to be snoozed in inbox and then switch over to normal Gmail and it'll still work fine. Then in Gmail, you can set up all your filters, switch over to inbox and it'll work fine. Yeah, it's amazing. And it's sort of annoying that like all the features aren't available in Gmail, you can set up all your filters, switch over to inbox, and it'll work fine. Yeah, it's amazing. And it's sort of annoying that, like, all the features aren't available in both. But, like, it works.
就像你可以在 Inbox 中发送要稍后提醒的消息，然后切换到普通 Gmail，它仍然可以正常工作。然后在 Gmail 中，你可以设置所有的过滤器，切换到 Inbox，它也会正常工作。是的，这太棒了。而且有点烦人的是，所有的功能在 Gmail 中都不可用，你可以设置所有的过滤器，切换到 Inbox，它也会正常工作。是的，这太棒了。而且有点烦人的是，所有的功能在两者中都不可用。但是，就像，它有效。
It's like two views into the same data set. It's really nice. Yeah, totally. Yeah, I think it's amazing. It's, like, it's so powerful that everything else just feels like it's in the stone age like if you're using outlook if you're using yes 10 male if you're using any any of these even thunderbird any of these things it feels like you're living in the stone age because it's more than just the male client and i know like you know there's a lot of concerns about google i i'm not dismissing those those
这就像是同一个数据集的两个视图。这真的很好。是的，完全正确。是的，我认为这太棒了。它，就像，它太强大了，以至于其他一切都感觉像是处于石器时代，如果你在使用 Outlook，如果你在使用 Yes 10 Mail，如果你在使用任何这些，甚至 Thunderbird，任何这些东西，感觉就像你生活在石器时代，因为它不仅仅是邮件客户端，而且我知道，像，你知道，有很多关于谷歌的担忧，我，我不是在驳回那些
concerns are very legitimate about you know sort of honoring privacy and sure what data they have yeah i i i'm sensitive to those as well but you know i i guess in this thing it's just so good it's compelling um yeah and and that's sort of scary yeah i know i got it but um the fact that when i you know my wife and i are looking at booking a trip and you know so we made some reservations for, you know, an airline and it sort of bundles those up together and creates, oh, you have a trip to this location. And then when we book our hotel, I know it'll bundle it into the same thing. And so then when I go, oh, I don't have to keep those things sort of in my active inbox. Oh gosh, like in the active display, I can send them away because I know I can go back to my trips and
担忧，关于，你知道，某种尊重隐私，当然他们有什么数据，是的，我，我，我对这些也很敏感，但你知道，我，我想在这件事上，它太好了，它很有吸引力，嗯，是的，而且这有点可怕，是的，我知道，我明白了，但是，嗯，事实是，当我，你知道，我和我妻子正在考虑预订一次旅行，而且，你知道，所以我们做了一些预订，为了，你知道，一家航空公司，它有点把那些捆绑在一起，创造了，哦，你有一个去这个地点的旅行。然后当我们预订酒店时，我知道它会把它捆绑到同一件事中。所以当我走的时候，哦，我不必把那些东西保留在我的活动收件箱中。哦，天哪，就像在活动显示中，我可以把它们发走，因为我知道我可以回到我的旅行中，
sorted by location and by date. I can just sort of click and it just has everything automatically organized without me having to do any work. Yeah, it's unbelievable. It's really nice. So it's like that added intelligence that they're down on, say, AI, because I think that's overused. But the sort of intelligence they're doing to sort of bundle up things in a in a smart way is is very nice i'm surprised that nobody has come out with a like pure desktop version of this where it still just uses imap or whatever but but once you get the email they do all sorts of this clever stuff
按地点和日期排序。我可以点击一下，它就自动组织好了一切，而不需要我做任何工作。是的，这太不可思议了。这真的很好。所以就像那种增加的智能，他们正在贬低，比如 AI，因为我认为那被过度使用了。但他们正在做的那种智能，以一种聪明的方式捆绑东西，是非常好的，我很惊讶没有人推出一个像纯桌面版本的东西，它仍然只是使用 IMAP 或其他什么，但一旦你收到电子邮件，他们就会做各种这种聪明的事情
it seems like it should be like i don't i i can't think of any obvious reason off the bat why other than you know like making it monetized like i can't figure out any reason why it wouldn't be possible yeah i feel the same way i mean one thing is the imap protocol is you know just not designed you know it's just not a modern protocol but but you could do this with like putting stuff in folders and then having like a special format for how to name the folders that your client like in the same way. Like you put them in a folder, but those folders have a special naming scheme that your application understands. Yeah, I think the issue is you either have to go all out. And by go all out, I mean you have to make an iPhone app, an Android app, a desktop. You have to do everything. Or you have to like
看起来它应该像，我不，我，我想不出任何明显的理由，除了，你知道，像让它货币化，我无法找出任何它不可能的理由，是的，我有同样的感觉，我的意思是，一件事是 IMAP 协议，你知道，只是没有设计，你知道，它只是不是一个现代协议，但你可以用它做，像把东西放在文件夹里，然后有一种特殊的格式来命名文件夹，你的客户端，像，以同样的方式。就像你把它们放在一个文件夹里，但那些文件夹有一种你的应用程序理解的特殊命名方案。是的，我认为问题在于你要么必须全力以赴。我的全力以赴是指你必须制作一个 iPhone 应用程序，一个 Android 应用程序，一个桌面。你必须做所有事情。或者你必须像
finagle everything into the IMAP protocol in a way where it doesn't look like garbage. It's not horrible to use. Yeah, I think that's the sort of probably the reason why it hasn't been done. But I mean, it's it's someone should try to figure it out. I mean, for the rest of our sakes. Yeah. And I guess it is like, I don't know't know how like i say that i really want it but then since i already have it for free like how much would i be willing to pay for you know like i don't know yeah that's true i mean other than at work um you know yeah you're only you'd only be targeting enterprise but then there's a lot of restrictions about that kind of stuff about where yeah it's a whole but anyways that's true if you're not this is just like sort of my opportunity to like gush a little bit about how much i've realized i really
以一种它看起来不像垃圾的方式把所有东西都塞进 IMAP 协议中。使用起来并不糟糕。是的，我认为这可能是它没有被完成的原因。但我的意思是，它，有人应该尝试弄清楚它。我的意思是，为了我们其余人的利益。是的。而且我想它是，我不知道，我怎么，像我说我真的很想要它，但既然我已经免费拥有它了，那么我愿意为，你知道，像，我不知道，是的，那是真的，我的意思是，除了在工作中，嗯，你知道，是的，你只会针对企业，但随后有很多关于那种事情的限制，关于在哪里，是的，这是一个整体，但无论如何，那是真的，如果你不是，这只是像，我的机会，像，滔滔不绝地谈论我意识到我有多么
do enjoy inbox like there's a lot of weird stuff initially but it's really just kept getting better and better and everything else just feels so bad to me yeah comparison yeah i agree i feel the same way so at first i was i thought it was awkward that you don't actually delete emails but i've gotten used to that. Yeah, and there's been times where I'm happy I didn't delete emails. Yeah, that's true too. Someone's going to write in and tell us to just use text-based email, but yeah, it's okay. That's right.
确实喜欢 Inbox，就像最初有很多奇怪的东西，但它真的只是越来越好，其他一切对我来说都感觉太糟糕了，是的，比较，是的，我同意，我有同样的感觉，所以起初我以为你不删除电子邮件很尴尬，但我已经习惯了。是的，而且有几次我很高兴我没有删除电子邮件。是的，那也是真的。有人会写信告诉我们只使用基于文本的电子邮件，但是的，没关系。那是对的。
Use Pine. So, all right. Time for cryptocurrency. All right, let's do it so i guess cryptocurrency is just the catch-all term for the the kind of new digital online currency that's backed by sort of cryptographic notions but i guess it's not a completely accurate description but we'll go with it i think it's a pretty commonly used one yeah i think it's it's the namesake um and and so the most common one the grandfather of them all the father of them, the root of the family tree was Bitcoin. There were previous digital currencies before that, you know, some famous, some infamous.
使用 Pine。所以，好吧。加密货币的时间到了。好吧，让我们做吧，所以我猜加密货币只是那种新的数字在线货币的统称，它由某种加密概念支持，但我猜这不是一个完全准确的描述，但我们会接受它，我认为这是一个相当常用的描述，是的，我认为它是，它是同名，而且，所以最常见的一个，所有人的祖父，他们的父亲，家族树的根源是比特币。在此之前有以前的数字货币，你知道，有些著名，有些臭名昭著。
But using this sort of the important thing here and what we're going to talk about in all these cryptocurrencies is the distributed distributed notion the notion that it isn't held by a central source um so if you took things like i mean yeah i mean like you could get credits like i don't macy's gift card an e-gift card or an itunes gift card but even like paypal and previously there was this like e-gold or whatever like you know i think on all of those cases i mean i'm not that familiar with equal but like you know they were held by a sort of central authority who you like Jason saying you pay dollars and they give you a quote unquote gift card, which is some ledger that they keep that says, you know, this thing, this dollar value was converted to this IOU. But if Macy's sort of goes away, the IOU is worthless. That's right.
但使用这种，这里重要的事情，以及我们将要在所有这些加密货币中谈论的是分布式，分布式概念，即它不是由中央来源持有的概念，所以如果你采取像，我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，你可以获得积分，像，我不，梅西百货礼品卡，电子礼品卡或 iTunes 礼品卡，但即使像 PayPal，之前有这个像 E-gold 或其他什么，像，你知道，我想在所有这些情况下，我的意思是，我对 E-gold 不太熟悉，但像，你知道，它们是由某种中央权威持有的，你，像杰森说的，你支付美元，他们给你一个所谓的礼品卡，这是一个他们保留的分类账，上面写着，你知道，这个东西，这个美元价值被转换成了这个借条。但如果梅西百货，你知道，消失了，借条就一文不值了。那是对的。
And so that's not true for cryptocurrency. They try to handle that in a different way. And you'll hear that at the distributed ledger. We'll talk more about it in a few minutes. But Bitcoin was sort of the, I guess, first one to get a lot of mainstream adoption. We've talked about it over the years. That sounds weird to say.
所以这对加密货币来说是不正确的。他们尝试以不同的方式处理这个问题。你会听到那是分布式分类账。我们几分钟后会更多地谈论它。但比特币是，我猜，第一个获得大量主流采用的。我们多年来一直在谈论它。说起来很奇怪。
But over the years, we've talked about it um on programming throwdown several times and in several different contexts and um yeah and you know how much of it we bought zero no i have i have 0.05 of a bitcoin that someone gave me that's right six years ago uh when i was like i created a wallet i was like i'm gonna try to mine a bitcoin um and you know never managed to actually mine a bitcoin on my laptop cpu um yeah and even at that time i don't know if it was even possible but there was somebody who had a website where if you gave them your id they would uh send you you know what at the time was i think i'd have to go look up i think it was like a penny
但多年来，我们一直在谈论它，嗯，在 Programming Throwdown 上谈论了好几次，在几个不同的背景下，嗯，是的，而且，你知道，我们买了多少？零，不，我有，我有 0.05 个比特币，有人给了我，那是对的，六年前，嗯，当我像，我创建了一个钱包，我想，我要尝试挖掘一个比特币，嗯，而且，你知道，从来没有设法在我的笔记本电脑 CPU 上实际挖掘一个比特币，嗯，是的，即使在那个时候，我不知道它是否甚至可能，但有一个人有一个网站，如果你给他们你的 ID，他们会，嗯，寄给你，你知道，当时是，我想我得去查一下，我想它就像一分钱
or a few cents um well today that's worth like 136 dollars so somewhat internet stranger thank you i don't know who you were but you gave me what is now worth 136 dollars which is amazing i haven't even uh not an even but i have a maybe opposing sad story which is um on my lab pc at university i set it it to mine a Bitcoin and I left it running for, I think, like almost the whole winter break. But then I, by the time I came back, I'd already forgotten about it. And I don't know if I even mined a Bitcoin or not. Maybe I mined 10 and I just exited the process and I have no idea what i did oh i know right uh so bitcoin was you know actually solves a sort of well-known set of problems that that didn't have good solutions
或者几美分，嗯，好吧，今天它价值 136 美元，所以某个互联网陌生人，谢谢你，我不知道你是谁，但你给了我现在价值 136 美元的东西，这太棒了，我甚至没有，嗯，不是一个甚至，但我有一个也许相反的悲伤故事，那就是，嗯，在大学的实验室电脑上，我设置它去挖掘一个比特币，我让它运行了，我想，像几乎整个寒假。但后来，当我回来时，我已经忘记了它。而且我不知道我是否甚至挖掘了一个比特币。也许我挖掘了 10 个，我只是退出了进程，我不知道我做了什么，哦，我知道，对吧，嗯，所以比特币是，你知道，实际上解决了一组众所周知的，没有好解决方案的问题
about how to do this consensus this distributed ledger stuff and it was written by a guy who's uh not his real name and no one actually to this day even as far as i know the public doesn't know who this this person is satoshi i don't know that's how you say it but um and this person created they published a paper they started doing this they actually mined you know a bunch of the first bitcoin and they sort of uh for a while were stewarding the kind of rollout of Bitcoin and how things are working. And then they sort of kind of went off the radar like they stopped doing anything. Now, maybe they just changed their their handle, their username, and they still are active in the community, but not under the, you know, not acting as the founder and creator of Bitcoin.
关于如何做这种共识，这种分布式分类账的东西，它是由一个家伙写的，嗯，不是他的真名，而且直到今天，据我所知，公众甚至不知道这个人是谁，中本聪，我不知道，那是你怎么说的，但，嗯，这个人创造了，他们发表了一篇论文，他们开始做这个，他们实际上挖掘了，你知道，一堆第一批比特币，而且他们有点，嗯，有一段时间在管理比特币的推出以及事情是如何运作的。然后他们有点，有点消失在雷达下，就像他们停止做任何事情。现在，也许他们只是改变了他们的句柄，他们的用户名，他们仍然在社区中活跃，但不是在，你知道，不是作为比特币的创始人和创造者。
But interestingly, like with Bitcoin's recent run-up which we'll talk about you know why these have dollar values make sense or not later um but with the current value i mean the the amount of bitcoin which is associated with satoshi is very i haven't looked at it recently but i mean it's it's an astronomical sum of money that he's he has under his possession but as far as people know they've never he's never actually exchanged any of those in for anything he's never transacted acted on the bitcoins that he has yeah that's right isn't that wild that there's somebody who owns i don't know what percent but it's significant of bitcoin and basically at any moment he could start selling um but yeah nothing has happened yet which gets an interesting thing like i guess at some point he would uh if he started selling like maybe the price would go down if it was significant but i bet oh i was
但有趣的是，像比特币最近的上涨，我们将谈论，你知道，为什么这些有美元价值，有意义与否，稍后，嗯，但以目前的价值，我的意思是，与中本聪相关的比特币数量是非常，我最近没有看它，但我的意思是，这是一个天文数字的钱，他拥有，但在人们所知范围内，他们从来没有，他从来没有实际交换过任何那些东西，他从来没有对比特币进行过交易，他拥有的，是的，那是对的，这不是很疯狂吗，有人拥有，我不知道百分之多少，但它是比特币的重要部分，基本上在任何时刻他都可以开始出售，嗯，但是的，什么都没有发生，这得到了一件有趣的事情，我猜在某个时候他会，嗯，如果他开始出售，像也许价格会下降，如果它是重要的，但我打赌，哦，我
gonna say i bet there's a bunch of people monitoring and if they see his wallet id they immediately sell everything so someone's saying that they've estimated it like that because it's not for certain for certain but about a million bitcoin wow which at today's prices would be is two billion dollars yeah that's crazy uh assuming assuming that he could actually liquidate all of it without causing the market to go down right right so let's talk about let's talk about that without causing the value to go down so actually do you want to talk about mining first and then well sure so briefly i want to talk about so we're going to talk at a high level about you know a lot of this sort of
要说，我打赌有一群人在监控，如果他们看到他的钱包 ID，他们会立即卖掉一切，所以有人说他们已经估计了它，像，因为它不是确定的，但大约一百万比特币，哇，以今天的价格，是 20 亿美元，是的，这太疯狂了，嗯，假设，假设他真的能清算所有这些而不导致市场下跌，对吧，对吧，所以让我们谈谈，让我们谈谈那个，而不导致价值下跌，所以实际上你想先谈谈挖掘，然后，嗯，当然，所以简要地，我想谈谈，所以我们将要谈论，在高层，关于，你知道，很多这种
uh interchangeably but quickly i just want to talk about also so another one the other big one besides bitcoin as far as market cap goes there's other things like dogecoin and litecoin and all but the other big one by market cap is ethereum. And we won't talk a lot about it here, but Ethereum has some interesting properties that are slightly different than Bitcoin and that you can sort of run automated scripts as part of the system, as part of the blockchain that it uses. And one of the most interesting experiments to me is this creation of the DAO, the Distributed Autonomous Organization, which was a series of scripts that allowed investors to sort of steal a ton of money from this DAO, this autonomous organization that people were voting in that was this corporation, steal many millions of dollars and hold the Bitcoin or hold the Ethereum sort of not hostage,
嗯，可互换地，但很快，我只是想谈谈，还有，所以另一个，除了比特币之外的另一个大的，就市值而言，还有像狗狗币和莱特币之类的东西，但按市值计算的另一个大的是以太坊。我们不会在这里谈论太多，但以太坊有一些有趣的属性，与比特币略有不同，你可以，像，运行自动化脚本作为系统的一部分，作为它使用的区块链的一部分。对我来说最有趣的实验之一是这个 DAO 的创建，分布式自治组织，这是一系列脚本，允许投资者，像，从这个 DAO，这个自治组织中窃取大量资金，人们在投票，那是这个公司，窃取数百万美元，并持有比特币，或持有以太坊，像，不是人质，
but hold it until they were going to presumably spend it. And instead, the whole Ethereum community basically decided to make a fork of the software to reach a consensus that basically those transactions were as if they never happened so the dow was never created the guy never stole it everyone just got their money back as if nothing happened um which is sort of crazy that is unbelievable yeah so so mining bitcoin or just you know sort of mining cryptocurrency is the notion of sort of doing some some work on your computer um some people talk about it's like searching for a prime number where you don't really know where a prime number is going to occur next they are oh i'm gonna mess this up because it has strong statements in number theory but i
而是持有它，直到他们大概要花掉它。相反，整个以太坊社区基本上决定对软件进行分叉，以达成共识，基本上那些交易就好像它们从未发生过一样，所以 DAO 从未被创建，那个人从未偷走它，每个人都拿回了他们的钱，就好像什么都没发生一样，嗯，这有点疯狂，这太不可思议了，是的，所以，所以挖掘比特币，或者只是，你知道，某种挖掘加密货币，是某种在你的计算机上做一些工作，嗯，有些人谈论它，就像搜索一个素数，你并不真正知道素数接下来会在哪里出现，它们是，哦，我会把这个搞砸，因为它在数论中有强有力的陈述，但我
always um forget exactly what it's but the just the distribution of primes is sort of like statistically known but you it's ran to the interspacing is random you never know how close or far you are to the next prime yep that's right um oh good i did it yay and so to sort of find a prime there's no good pattern. You should obviously sort of skip the even numbers. But aside from that, there's no real pattern. You kind of have to check every number along the way and see if it factors or not. And similarly, when you're mining Bitcoin, what's happening is a new Bitcoin is,
总是，嗯，忘记它到底是什么，但只是素数的分布，有点像统计学上已知的，但你，它是随机的，间隔是随机的，你永远不知道你离下一个素数有多近或多远，是的，那是对的，嗯，哦，太好了，我做到了，耶，所以为了，像，找到一个素数，没有好的模式。你显然应该跳过偶数。但除此之外，没有真正的模式。你必须检查沿途的每个数字，看看它是否能分解。同样，当你挖掘比特币时，正在发生的是一个新的比特币是，
and we'll just use Bitcoin in this example, a new Bitcoin is being created and the person who successfully mines it gets to own that Bitcoin. And the Bitcoin itself is equivalent to trying to find a number which combined with a bunch of transactions that have happened in Bitcoin and some hashing and cryptographic signing but basically finding an input that you modify finding a value that makes the results match a certain pattern and when it matches that pattern that you reach a hash of a certain you know description then you've sort of mined the bitcoin and so everybody is sort of working to try to mine the next Bitcoin block. And whoever finds it first, because it's sort of random, you're just randomly trying numbers. And whoever finds it first sort of gets that Bitcoin. And so it's like this big race to find
我们将在这个例子中使用比特币，一个新的比特币正在被创建，成功挖掘它的人拥有那个比特币。比特币本身等同于试图找到一个数字，它与比特币中发生的一堆交易和一些哈希和加密签名相结合，但基本上找到一个你修改的输入，找到一个使结果匹配某种模式的值，当它匹配该模式时，你达到某种，你知道，描述的哈希，那么你就已经挖掘了比特币，所以每个人都在努力尝试挖掘下一个比特币区块。谁先找到它，因为它有点随机，你只是随机尝试数字。谁先找到它，就得到那个比特币。所以这就像这场大比赛，去寻找
it out. And this all gets really confusing. So we'll have a link to a little tutorial like video and description interactive, not of the full bitcoin protocol which is quite in depth but of notionally how all of this works at sort of a simple level um right and you can check that out at anders.com slash blockchain uh this was really helpful to me and the first time i kind of really understood a lot of this was sort of going through this and understanding ah this is how this works yeah i mean a lot of it comes down to what we talked about in our cryptography episode, which is like these non-reversible mathematical operators, right? Like, for example, let's say I told you, you know, what's 2 plus 2?
它。而且这一切变得非常令人困惑。所以我们将有一个链接到一个小教程，像视频和描述交互式，不是完整的比特币协议，它是相当深入的，而是概念上所有这些是如何在某种简单层面上工作的，嗯，对，你可以在 anders.com/blockchain 查看它，这对我有很大帮助，我第一次真正理解很多这些东西，是某种通过这个，并理解，啊，这就是它的工作原理，是的，我的意思是，很多归结为我们在我们的密码学剧集中谈论的内容，也就是像这些不可逆的数学运算符，对吧？比如，假设我告诉你，你知道，2 加 2 是多少？
Or let's say, let's get down to the reason, what's 1 plus 3? You'd say 4. It's very easy, right? Let's assume for a moment that there wasn't subtraction, like addition was somehow not reversible. And I just gave you four and you had to give me the one and the three. That's hard, right? Because it could be zero plus four. It could be four plus zero. It could be two plus two. It could be three plus one. It could be one plus three. Or, you know, if you get a negative numbers, let's forget about negative numbers for now. But there's all these different possibilities. And there's no way to know, like, if I'm holding the one and the three, and I'm asking you, you know, hey, I have two numbers added up to four, what are they? Or even if I give you one, if I say, here's a one, give me the number that, you know,
或者让我们谈谈原因，1 加 3 是多少？你会说 4。这很容易，对吧？让我们暂时假设没有减法，就像加法在某种程度上是不可逆的。我只是给了你 4，你必须给我 1 和 3。这很难，对吧？因为它可以是 0 加 4。它可以是 4 加 0。它可以是 2 加 2。它可以是 3 加 1。它可以是 1 加 3。或者，你知道，如果你得到负数，让我们暂时忘记负数。但有所有这些不同的可能性。而且没有办法知道，像，如果我拿着 1 和 3，我在问你，你知道，嘿，我有两个数字加起来等于 4，它们是什么？或者即使我给你一个，如果我说，这是一个 1，给我那个数字，你知道，
that plus one is equal to four. And again, let's assume there's no subtraction we're in a universe without subtraction, there's nothing you really do, you just have to try all the numbers, is 1 plus 1 4, is 1 plus 2 4 is 1 plus 3 4, okay, now obviously there's subtraction you just invert the addition, right but there are some operators you cannot invert. And so that's basically somebody gives you, you know, one, they give you two of the three parts. They say, like, X, and then it's operator, and then Y is equal to this new number, Z. But you don't know what Y is, and you have to kind of figure it out.
那个加 1 等于 4。而且再次，让我们假设没有减法，我们在一个没有减法的宇宙中，你真的什么都做不了，你只是必须尝试所有的数字，1 加 1 是 4 吗，1 加 2 是 4 吗，1 加 3 是 4 吗，好吧，现在显然有减法，你只是反转加法，对吧，但有些运算符你无法反转。所以这基本上是有人给你，你知道，1，他们给你三个部分中的两个。他们说，像，X，然后是运算符，然后 Y 等于这个新数字，Z。但你不知道 Y 是什么，你必须弄清楚它。
And there's no good way to do it other than just trying a bunch of numbers there's heuristics and things like that but there's nothing like guaranteed um so so yeah you have to do a lot of work to to get a bitcoin right so you have to solve this mathematical problem that's again it's easy to create but if you're not the creator it's hard to solve um and so that's a cost. Like your computer's gonna have to spend some energy to do that. And you're gonna have to spend some time. The maintainer of that computer is gonna have to spend at least a little bit of time to do that. And that means that that has value. So if you talk about, you know, what gives something value, it's basically three things. The first is the
而且没有好的方法来做它，除了只是尝试一堆数字，有启发式方法和类似的东西，但没有什么像保证，嗯，所以，是的，你必须做很多工作才能得到一个比特币，对吧？所以你必须解决这个数学问题，它再次，很容易创建，但如果你不是创造者，它很难解决，嗯，所以这是一个成本。就像你的计算机将不得不花费一些能量来做这件事。而且你将不得不花费一些时间。那台计算机的维护者将不得不花费至少一点时间来做这件事。这意味着它有价值。所以如果你谈论，你知道，什么赋予了某物价值，它基本上是三件事。第一是
amount of labor. Like for example, uh, you know, diamonds are very hard to get. Like I can't just, you know, go outside in the backyard and scoop up some diamonds. And so because of that, there's going to be an intrinsic value there. Like even if diamonds were like smelly and looked ugly, you know, as long as somebody needed a diamond for something and it's very hard to get, then that person's going to spend a lot of money on it. Think of like a moon rock, like a moon rock is so hard to get. And so even though it pretty much just looks like a regular rock, it's very valuable, right? The next is sort of psychological value. Like a diamond is going to be worth more than, say, an emerald. And it's really just because of, you know, humanity. Like
劳动量。比如，嗯，你知道，钻石很难得到。就像我不能只是，你知道，走到后院，舀起一些钻石。所以因为那个，那里会有内在价值。就像即使钻石是，像，臭的，看起来很丑，你知道，只要有人需要钻石做某事，而且它很难得到，那么那个人就会花很多钱在它上面。想想像月球岩石，像月球岩石很难得到。所以即使它看起来几乎就像一块普通的岩石，它也非常有价值，对吧？接下来是某种心理价值。像钻石会比，比如，祖母绿更值钱。而且这真的只是因为，你知道，人类。像
we've sort of decided on that, right? There are some things like an iPhone has a very large profit margin, which means they could make it cheaper and still make money, but they don't because they figure out that enough people are going to buy it at the high price. And that's psychological, right? Another one is the historical trend. So, you know, if an iPhone is going for sale for, let's say, $500, even if something kind of drastic happens, unless there is kind of like a widespread panic, something that's public that really gets out there, things tend to just be worth what they're worth. Like there are things that kind of tend to just hold their value to some degree, or they depreciate, but it's kind of a known quantity. And the depreciation factor, there's some inertia there.
我们已经决定了这一点，对吧？有些东西像 iPhone 有很大的利润率，这意味着他们可以把它做得更便宜，仍然赚钱，但他们没有，因为他们算出足够多的人会以高价购买它。那是心理上的，对吧？另一个是历史趋势。所以，你知道，如果 iPhone 以，比如，500 美元出售，即使发生了一些相当剧烈的事情，除非有某种像广泛的恐慌，某种公开的东西真正传出去，事情往往只是值它们所值的。就像有些东西往往只是在某种程度上保持它们的价值，或者它们贬值，但它是一种已知的数量。而且贬值因素，那里有一些惯性。
And so those three things pretty much describe why anything costs what it does. It's some composition of those three factors, right? And so Bitcoin has all three of them. There is a certain amount of labor to get a Bitcoin. The psychological value is is you know it's been around for a long enough time and enough people have kind of agreed and enough people have turned it into money and invite and back into bitcoin that that people are sort of mentally they're comfortable with it and it has a trend like it has some upward trajectory it
所以这三点基本上解释了为什么任何东西都有其价格。它是这三个因素的某种组合，对吧？比特币也具备这三点。获取比特币需要一定的劳动。心理价值在于，你知道它已经存在了足够长的时间，足够多的人已经认可了它，并将其转化为货币，然后再换回比特币，所以人们在心理上已经适应了它，而且它有一种趋势，即它有一定的上升轨迹。
didn't just you know become super valuable overnight and if bitcoin all of a sudden was worth you know a cent and then it jumped back to its original price that would have a big impact like it would probably never recover because because the trend is very important well so the um oh go ahead yeah the value of bitcoin has shot up like you know because of a lot of speculation people basically buying because they think it's going to go up because it has gone up um yeah well that's true i guess i guess uh yeah by the historical trend i mean like uh over the course of let's say a day or an hour or something like that. Okay. Like if you knew that you could get a Bitcoin for half the price tomorrow, or even if you knew that there was just enormous volatility,
它并不是一夜之间变得非常有价值的。如果比特币突然只值一分钱，然后又跳回原来的价格，那会产生很大的影响，因为它可能永远无法恢复，因为趋势非常重要。嗯，那个……哦，你继续。是的，比特币的价值飙升是因为大量的投机行为，人们买入基本上是因为他们认为它会涨，因为它确实涨了。嗯，是的，我想那是真的。我猜……是的，我所说的历史趋势是指，比如说在一天或一小时之内的情况。好的。就像如果你知道明天能以半价买到比特币，或者即使你知道那里有巨大的波动，
then you probably wouldn't buy one. Unless you were like, at that point, it's basically gambling. And gambling is kind of like a different sort of system, right? Yeah. And you didn't sort of mention, but I mean, there's also the notion here of the like use of a thing so like some stuff is valuable because it has i guess you sort of set intrinsic value is is the way that captures but like this thing is value to me because it gives me something it either helps me do something yeah you're right actually i totally missed that but that is that is the fourth uh piece of the puzzle well so like i mean you said intrinsic value which is part of that is you know
那你可能就不会买了。除非你觉得，到了那个地步，这基本上就是赌博了。而赌博是另一种系统，对吧？是的。你没有提到，但我的意思是，这里还有一个关于事物用途的概念，比如有些东西有价值是因为它有……我想你称之为内在价值，这是捕捉这一点的说法，但比如这个东西对我来说有价值，因为它给了我某种东西，它要么帮助我做某事。是的，你说得对，我完全忽略了这一点，但那是拼图的第四块。嗯，所以就像你说的内在价值，其中一部分是，你知道
it's like you know gold is used in some industrial processes and it's useful i mean it's more expensive than it's only its industrial uses but even if they went away it would still be useful to be able to like gold is not it doesn't tarnish and corrode very easily. So it's really great for, you know, contacts on like, that's why I like the ends of headphone plugs are sometimes gold plated because they don't corrode and get worse over time. Right.
就像黄金被用于一些工业过程，它是很有用的。我的意思是，它比仅仅用于工业用途要昂贵得多，但即使那些用途消失了，它仍然是有用的，比如黄金不容易失去光泽和腐蚀。所以它非常适合，你知道，比如耳机插头的末端有时是镀金的，因为它们不会随着时间的推移而腐蚀和变差。没错。
It has use. And in that way, you know, you kind of do have use of Bitcoin, which would, you know, talk about a minute, but the distributed nature,
它有用途。从这个意义上说，你知道，你确实对比特币有用途，我们一会儿会谈到，但其分布式特性，
the way it works, it has a value in that Jason and I can exchange money in a very low fee kind of way. And that has use and that does give it value. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, it has some amount of utility, especially, yeah, Patrick will talk about it later, but there's some times where Bitcoin is the only thing you can convert to. And so that gives it even more utility. So one thing people might ask is, like, how is the price figured out? Right. You know, there's some of these like psychological value.
它的工作方式，它的价值在于杰森和我可以用一种低费用的方式交换货币。这有用途，也赋予了它价值。是的，这很有道理。是的，它确实有一定的效用，特别是……是的，帕特里克稍后会谈到，但有时比特币是你唯一可以转换的东西。所以这赋予了它更多的效用。所以人们可能会问的一件事是，价格是如何计算出来的？对吧。你知道，这其中有一些心理价值。
Like, how do you measure that? Right. It turns out you don't. So this is something that you cannot sort of there's no closed form equation. You can't just plug in a bunch of things and get the value out. Instead, what happens is it's a dynamical system. So in other words, you might not know the equation for gravity, but you know that if you throw a rock up, it's going to come back down.
比如，你如何衡量这一点？对吧。事实证明你无法衡量。所以这是你无法……没有封闭形式的方程。你不能只是输入一堆东西然后得出价值。相反，它是一个动力系统。换句话说，你可能不知道重力方程，但你知道如果你把一块石头扔上去，它会掉下来。
And you might even be able to estimate like how many seconds it's going to take to come down. You don't have to be like a physicist or even know the equations or anything. You're just kind of observing and you have sort of a mental model, right? So this is the same way. So the Bitcoin is traded on an exchange similar to a stock or anything else. And in the case of stock, it's on the New York Stock Exchange or the London Stock Exchange or I think Shanghai or what have you. In the case of cryptocurrency, there's a variety of exchanges. There's Coinbase and Gemini here in America. Actually, Coinbase probably, both of
你甚至可能能够估计它掉下来需要多少秒。你不必成为物理学家，甚至不需要知道方程什么的。你只是在观察，并且有某种心理模型，对吧？所以这同样适用。比特币是在交易所交易的，类似于股票或其他任何东西。如果是股票，它是在纽约证券交易所、伦敦证券交易所或我想上海证券交易所等等。如果是加密货币，有各种各样的交易所。在美国有 Coinbase 和 Gemini。实际上，Coinbase 可能……这两者
those are probably international, but there are some countries that can't use Coinbase. There's a list of different exchanges you can find online. And the way all of these exchanges work is the same. It's basically a double auction. So what that means is every, let's say, millisecond, the system looks at its orders, like who wants to buy and at what price. And it looks at its sell orders, who wants to sell and at what price. And it matches those people up. And there's a variety of strategies, but basically, you know, I think the person who wants to buy at the highest price right there at that millisecond
可能都是国际性的，但有些国家不能使用 Coinbase。你可以在网上找到各种交易所的列表。所有这些交易所的工作方式都是一样的。它基本上是一个双向拍卖。这意味着，每隔，比如说，一毫秒，系统就会查看它的订单，比如谁想买，以什么价格。它也会查看它的卖单，谁想卖，以什么价格。然后它会匹配这些人。虽然有各种策略，但基本上，你知道，我认为在那个毫秒内想以最高价格买入的人
gets matched up with the person who wants to sell at the, I think at the highest price, if I remember correctly. Yeah, that's right. So the person wants to buy at the highest price, if I remember correctly. Yeah, that's right. So the person wants to buy at the highest price gets matched up with the person who wants to sell at the highest price. And then that transaction happens. Those people, assuming that the person who wants to buy, wants to buy at a higher price than the person who wants to sell that transaction happens. And I think it happens at the seller's price um and then those two people walk away happy with their transaction then we take them out and we look at what's left and we just keep doing this until the person the people who want to buy all want to buy for less than the the
会与想以……如果我没记错的话，想以最高价格卖出的人匹配。是的，没错。所以想以最高价格买入的人，如果我没记错的话。是的，没错。所以想以最高价格买入的人会与想以最高价格卖出的人匹配。然后交易就发生了。这些人，假设想买的人想以比想卖的人更高的价格买入，那么交易就发生了。而且我认为它是以卖方的价格发生的。嗯，然后那两个人对他们的交易感到满意，然后我们把他们剔除，看看还剩下什么，我们一直这样做，直到想买的人都想以低于……
most expensive seller right so if i want to sell for a dollar least expensive seller uh they want to buy for less than the least expensive seller then the least i get the right than the yeah so if i well if i if i want to sell for a dollar and there's someone else wants to sell for two dollars and there's someone who's willing to buy for uh1.50. Yeah, you're right. Yeah. So eventually it's going to get to the point where there's a bunch of people who want to buy, but they all want to buy for, let's say, $1 and all the people who want to sell want to sell for $2. So now nobody can make a transaction. So then the system sort of ticks. It takes new orders and it starts a new millisecond and it starts this whole process over again.
最昂贵的卖方（的价格）买入，对吧？所以如果我想以一美元卖出……最便宜的卖方……他们想以低于最便宜卖方的价格买入，那么最便宜的……我得到了正确的……是的。所以如果我……嗯，如果我想以一美元卖出，而有另一个人想以两美元卖出，并且有一个人愿意以1.50美元买入。是的，你说得对。是的。所以最终会达到这样一个点，有一群人想买，但他们都想以，比如说，1美元买入，而所有想卖的人都想以2美元卖出。所以现在没有人能进行交易。于是系统就会跳动。它接收新的订单，开始一个新的毫秒，并重新开始整个过程。
And so what happens is, you know, people put in orders and those orders can't be fulfilled. And their reaction is to put in a higher order if they really want whatever the person is selling. And so in this way, the double auction kind of self heals, it self regulates. Nobody really knows what the price should be, but it's this dynamical system that's constantly adapting. But we say the price is the last successful transaction amount. That's right, yeah. I mean, this gets back to the trend part.
所以发生的情况是，你知道，人们输入订单，而这些订单无法完成。他们的反应是，如果他们真的想要卖方正在卖的东西，就会输入更高的订单。通过这种方式，双向拍卖会自我修复，自我调节。没有人真正知道价格应该是多少，但这是一个不断适应的动力系统。但我们说价格是最后一次成功的交易金额。没错，是的。我的意思是，这回到了趋势的部分。
So that's the price at which we last knew that a transaction took place, and therefore two parties agreed that the value was that. to another one for a penny. Like let's say something's worth $1,000 and I make a bunch of fake agents and I keep having them sell this product to each other for a penny. You know, if I own all the agents, you know, it looks like something's worth a penny, but it's really not.
所以这就是我们最后一次知道发生交易的价格，因此双方都同意价值就是那个数额。……给另一个人一分钱。比如，假设某样东西值1000美元，我制造了一堆虚假代理人，并不断让他们以一分钱的价格把这个产品卖给对方。你知道，如果我拥有所有的代理人，你知道，看起来某样东西值一分钱，但实际上并非如此。
It's really me sort of gaming the system. And there's all sorts of like inertia terms and things like that to compensate for that. And that's where the historical part comes in. That would have to happen at a very high volume for a long time before they would say, oh, I guess this really is worth a penny. The other thing, too, is there's always an opportunity for someone else to be buying.
这实际上是我在操纵系统。而且有各种各样的惯性项之类的东西来补偿这一点。这就是历史部分发挥作用的地方。这必须在高交易量下持续很长时间，他们才会说，哦，我想这真的只值一分钱。另一件事是，总是有其他人买入的机会。
I can't guarantee that I'm going to buy my own thing. But yeah, in this case, I mean mean this is the exchange being fair right it has actually nothing to do with bitcoin so bitcoin itself doesn't facilitate exchanging into into dollars what you sort of need is if jason and via some facility jason and I could agree in person that Jason's going to give me $20 and I'm going to give him $20. I'm going to send his wallet $20 worth of Bitcoin. We could do that in person. That's an exchange.
我不能保证我一定会买我自己的东西。但是的，在这种情况下，我的意思是，这是交易所的公平性，对吧？这实际上与比特币无关，所以比特币本身并不促进兑换成美元。你所需要的是，如果杰森和我通过某种设施，杰森和我可以在当面达成一致，杰森给我20美元，我给他20美元。我要往他的钱包里发送价值20美元的比特币。我们可以在当面这样做。那是一次交换。
But there's a lot of risks there. Like one of us has to go first. Either Jason has to give me the $20 or I have to send the Bitcoin. And that causes a problem, which is why you have these exchanges is because they act as a third party to sort of facilitate that transaction. And so I don't I mean, I assume I don't actually I've not checked on Coinbase. But I mean, I assume the way it works is basically I send money. I send my dollars to Coinbase when I agree to something. I sort of hold dollars in my account and I agree to let Coinbase take some of those and give them to someone else. Once that person has given the coins to Coinbase that they can give to me.
但那里有很多风险。比如我们其中一个人必须先行动。要么杰森必须给我20美元，要么我必须发送比特币。这导致了一个问题，这就是为什么你有这些交易所，因为它们充当第三方来促进这种交易。所以我并不……我的意思是，我假设……我实际上没有在 Coinbase 上查过。但我的意思是，我假设它的工作方式基本上是我发送钱。当我同意某事时，我把我的美元发送给 Coinbase。我把美元存在我的账户里，我同意让 Coinbase 取走其中的一些并给别人。一旦那个人把币给了 Coinbase，他们就可以给我。
And so they act as a broker. They broker the deal to make sure that no one has to deal with the fact of someone flaking out. Right. So when they are doing this double auction at that moment, they have power over both sides. I mean, they could theoretically take my money and take the other person's Bitcoin. But, you know, we trust them. There's a variety of sort of social systems in place to keep that from happening. And so why is why are people wanting to convert their hard-earned cash? We talked about before Jason working his job selling popcorn. Why is he turning that into Bitcoin? And there's a couple of reasons. We talked about that this being distributed, there's no big bank, right?
所以他们充当经纪人。他们撮合交易，以确保没有人需要处理有人反悔的事实。对吧。所以当他们在那个时刻进行这种双向拍卖时，他们对双方都有权力。我的意思是，他们理论上可以拿走我的钱，拿走另一个人的比特币。但是，你知道，我们信任他们。有各种各样的社会制度来防止这种情况发生。那么为什么人们想要转换他们辛苦赚来的现金呢？我们之前谈到杰森做着卖爆米花的工作。他为什么要把它变成比特币？有几个原因。我们谈到它是分布式的，没有大银行，对吧？
So Jason talked about like, oh, the exchange should just take all your money and run. It turns out that banks could do that. And the u.s we have lots of different kinds of protections that try to prevent a bank from sort of like going bankrupt oh dear um and and taking all of your money but you know it has happened in the past that's why those regulations are there um right but there's also lots of fees associated with lots of things that you do when you work with a bank um and the bank gets to control and set a lot of that stuff because you're sort of forced to in some ways in order to operate in society to kind of use that it's very hard to go around spending actual dollars like storing dollars under your mattress and then
所以杰森谈到，哦，交易所应该拿走你所有的钱然后跑路。事实证明银行可以那样做。在美国，我们有很多不同种类的保护措施，试图防止银行破产……哦，天哪……并拿走你所有的钱，但你知道，过去确实发生过，这就是为什么有那些法规存在……对吧，但当你与银行合作时，也有很多与你所做的许多事情相关的费用……而且银行可以控制和设定很多这些东西，因为你在某种程度上被迫这样做，为了在社会中运作，不得不使用它。很难绕过它去花实际的美元，比如把美元存放在床垫下，然后
using them everywhere and even if you were to do that that's actually sort of dangerous because if you get robbed and someone looks under your mattress, all your money's gone. And so all of these things come into play. And so Bitcoin is nice because it's distributed. There isn't a central bank. And so it's very, very easy if sort of one person, one Bitcoin was trying to charge, there is a little bit of a, we won't go into it because it's complicated on how sort of transaction fees work in the system. But they're much lower than sort of paying with a credit card for instance and so if jason were to try to get like greedy and charge a higher transaction fee for me to use his services to to transact bitcoin uh then other people would just sort of undercut him because
到处使用它们，即使你那样做了，那实际上也是危险的，因为如果你被抢劫了，有人往你的床垫下看，你所有的钱都没了。所以所有这些事情都发挥了作用。所以比特币很好，因为它是分布式的。没有中央银行。所以如果一个人，一个比特币试图收费，这是非常非常容易的，虽然我们不会深入探讨，因为它很复杂，关于系统中的交易费用是如何运作的。但它们比用信用卡支付要低得多，例如，如果杰森试图变得贪婪，对我使用他的服务来交易比特币收取更高的交易费用，那么其他人就会以更低的价格抢走他的生意，因为
it's this very competitive decentralized thing um there's no reason to use jason versus just random other people um and so exactly that makes it really resistant to sort of one person acting in bad faith like one person doing bad you need a consensus of people you need very very large numbers of in this case we say people but it's actually computers agents you need a large number of them to be essentially agreeing to collude and commit commit bad things and we're sort of trusting that because we think that lots and lots of different people with all different desires aren't going to want to collude to cheat me that this is a safe thing um the other thing is that people say oh bitcoin is anonymous and that's why um it's useful because it's really good for you know
这是一个竞争非常激烈的去中心化事物……没有理由使用杰森而不是随机的其他人的服务……所以正是这一点使它非常抵制一个人恶意行事，比如一个人做坏事。你需要人们的共识，你需要非常非常多的人，在这种情况下我们说是人，但实际上是计算机代理，你需要大量的它们来本质上同意串通并做坏事。我们之所以信任这一点，是因为我们认为许多许多有着不同欲望的不同人不会想要串通来欺骗我，所以这是一件安全的事情……另一件事是人们说哦比特币是匿名的，这就是为什么……它很有用，因为它非常适合，你知道
buying drugs or whatever you know that you want to be anonymous but it's actually being very careful it is not anonymous um so it is sued anonymous which is that no one sees, you know, my social security number or my name. It's just my, my wallet, my address, you know, my special series of numbers, um, that's unique to me, but no one knows that that is me. And so I can go online. I can have people send money to that address. I can send money from that address and no one knows it's me, but they do know it's that address. I can send money from that address. And no one knows it's me, but they do know it's that address. Like, yeah, that's different than anonymous because anonymous, you wouldn't know who it was. This, you don't know who it is, but you know that it's the same person between any two given transactions. Exactly. And the reason why that's really important. So for instance, like we said at the beginning, Satoshi, if he were to get rid of all his Bitcoin and the price didn't go down, they'd be worth billions of dollars right the reason we know that satoshi owns those is because they're the very first we know whose unique fingerprint created those first
买毒品什么的，你知道你想要匿名，但实际上要非常小心，它不是匿名的……它是假名，也就是说没有人看到，你知道，我的社会安全号码或我的名字。它只是我的，我的钱包，我的地址，你知道，我的一串特殊的数字，……那是对我唯一的，但没有人知道那就是我。所以我可以上网。我可以让人把钱汇到那个地址。我可以从那个地址汇钱，没有人知道是我，但他们确实知道是那个地址。我可以从那个地址汇钱。没有人知道是我，但他们确实知道是那个地址。就像，是的，这与匿名不同，因为匿名的话，你不会知道那是谁。这个，你不知道那是谁，但你知道在任何两次给定的交易之间，那是同一个人。没错。而这之所以非常重要。所以例如，就像我们在开头说的，中本聪，如果他要处理掉他所有的比特币而价格没有下跌，它们将价值数十亿美元。我们知道中本聪拥有那些比特币的原因是，它们是最初的。我们知道是谁的独特指纹创造了那些最初的
bitcoins and we can see that fingerprint doesn't occur in subsequent transactions so those bitcoins most of them weren't sort of moved around um and so we assume that must be him and now we can monitor and say if any of those any bitcoins come out of that address then he must be selling his bitcoin and in that way it's not anonymous but it is super anonymous you know if the if if uh let's say hypothetically there's, there's a certain like Bitcoin address that's like buying, like being used in all sorts of like drug deals and stuff like that. And the police catch a drug dealer. And when they catch him, they get his computer. They can like, you know, get his Bitcoin wallet ID and they can look in the history and see all the transactions he's done.
比特币，我们可以看到那个指纹并没有出现在随后的交易中，所以那些比特币，它们中的大多数并没有被转移……所以我们假设那一定是他，现在我们可以监控并说，如果任何那些比特币从那个地址出来，那么他一定是在卖他的比特币。从这个意义上说，它不是匿名的，但它是超级匿名的。你知道，如果……如果……嗯，假设有一个特定的比特币地址，它被用于各种毒品交易之类的。警察抓到了一个毒贩。当他们抓到他时，他们得到了他的电脑。他们可以，你知道，得到他的比特币钱包 ID，他们可以查看历史记录，看到他所做的所有交易。
Well, I mean, it gets worse, right? wallet id and they can look in the history and see all the transactions he's done well i mean it gets worse right so if someone were to you know these hackers like oh send money to my bitcoin right um as long as if they continue to sort of move bitcoin around for purely digital other pseudonymous or anonymous systems there's no problem but fundamentally ultimately jason wants to buy an iphone uh or an android phone maybe one of those cool slick s8s uh or whatever he wants to buy a phone and so he needs hard cold benjamins you know dollars and so at some point jason wants to after doing this massive hacking scheme he wants to convert his bitcoin to dollars now it turns out this is this this becomes a dilemma because someone now has to give him U.S. dollars, U.S. currency. And once you do that, you tend to be something that's more regulated by the government.
嗯，我的意思是，情况变得更糟了，对吧？钱包 ID，他们可以查看历史记录，看到他所做的所有交易。嗯，我的意思是，情况变得更糟了，对吧？所以如果有人要……你知道这些黑客，哦，把钱汇到我的比特币地址……只要他们继续以纯数字或其他假名或匿名系统转移比特币，就没有问题。但从根本上，最终杰森想要买一部 iPhone……或者一部安卓手机，也许是那些酷炫的 S8 之一……或者无论他想买什么手机，所以他需要硬通货，你知道，美元。所以杰森在进行这种大规模黑客计划后，在某个时候想要把他的比特币转换成美元。现在事实证明，这……这变成了一个困境，因为现在有人必须给他美元，美国货币。一旦你那样做了，你往往会成为受政府监管的东西。
And so they probably have some sort of log. So as soon as he tries to do business with a business. Oh, that was confusing as soon as he tries to exchange his bitcoins with a business that either needs to mail him something send him u.s currency or foreign current most foreign currencies have the same rules as soon as he needs to touch sort of physical goods then there if the police go to that business and basically say you have to give us your records they have to comply and now people will figure out they'll be able to match Jason's account with his person. Yeah, exactly. Uh, so yeah. So pseudonymous useful in a lot of circumstances, but not a great idea if you really want to commit crime. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Um, um, yeah. So, so how does it work? So basically, um, you know,
所以他们可能有一些日志。所以一旦他试图与一家企业做生意。哦，那很令人困惑。一旦他试图与一家企业交换他的比特币，而该企业要么需要给他邮寄东西，要么给他发送美元或外币……大多数外币都有相同的规则。一旦他需要接触某种实物商品，那么如果警察去那家企业，基本上说你必须给我们你的记录，他们必须遵守。现在人们会发现，他们将能够把杰森的账户与他本人匹配起来。是的，没错。嗯，所以是的。所以假名在很多情况下很有用，但如果你真的想犯罪，这不是一个好主意。是的，是的，没错。嗯，嗯，是的。所以，所以它是如何工作的？所以基本上，嗯，你知道，
like what's to stop me from just saying, oh, Patrick gave me a million dollars, everybody. So basically, it's similar to cryptography. It's similar to the the public private key stuff that we talked about in that episode. So definitely go and check that episode out. But just to kind of rehash it, you know, everyone has a private key. If someone gets your private key they can take all your money right um so uh assuming that doesn't happen so i with my private key you know i sign some some uh some package is it i guess it's a blockchain or no a message so you create a transaction you create a transaction it says i want to pay patrick lots of money right i want to pay pat lots of money. Right.
比如有什么能阻止我只是说，哦，帕特里克给了我一百万美元，大家。所以基本上，它类似于密码学。它类似于我们在那一集中谈到的公钥私钥的东西。所以一定要去看看那一集。但只是为了重温一下，你知道，每个人都有一个私钥。如果有人得到了你的私钥，他们就可以拿走你所有的钱，对吧？嗯……所以……假设那没有发生，所以我用我的私钥，你知道，我签署了一些……一些……一些包，它是区块链吗？还是不，一条消息。所以你创建了一个交易，你创建了一个交易，它说我想付给帕特里克很多钱，对吧？我想付给帕特很多钱。没错。
I want to pay Patrick all the money that I got for deploying this worm. Oh, no, no, no. I don't want that money. So I want to give Patrick a bunch of money, and I sign it with my private key. So one thing about this whole blockchain is that everyone has the entire state. So imagine if you went to Facebook.com or you went to, let's say, Yahoo.com. And, you know, the first time you went to Yahoo.com, they gave you the entire database, like with everything. And they're like, hang on, hang on, buddy.
我想付给帕特我部署这个蠕虫病毒所得到的所有钱。哦，不，不，不。我不想要那笔钱。所以我想要给帕特一笔钱，我用我的私钥签署它。所以关于这个整个区块链的一件事是，每个人都有整个状态。所以想象一下，如果你去了 Facebook.com 或者你去了，比如说，Yahoo.com。而且，你知道，你第一次去 Yahoo.com 时，他们给了你整个数据库，就像包含所有东西一样。他们就像，等等，等等，伙计。
We need to give you the entire database. It's like everyone's records, everyone's name, everything. And then you would get all of that. And then they would say, okay, now what do you want to do at Yahoo? And you wouldn't even have to contact them anymore other than just to get updates because you have literally the entire back end of Yahoo. And I know this to be true because my 0.05 Bitcoin
我们需要给你整个数据库。就像每个人的记录，每个人的名字，所有东西。然后你就会得到所有这些。然后他们会说，好的，现在你想在雅虎做什么？你甚至不需要再联系他们，除了只是为了获取更新，因为你实际上拥有雅虎的整个后端。我知道这是真的，因为我的 0.05 比特币
that I had on an old laptop that I recently got back out, I downloaded the client migrated my wallet and then had to wait for you know many i think it was like a day or two while my computer basically downloaded the entire state of the blockchain and fast forwarded to make sure that there was no transaction that so there was a transaction from anonymous kind internet stranger to me five years six years ago and that there was no transaction anywhere in the blockchain after that, that sort of my 0.05 Bitcoin were sent somewhere else. Right, exactly. So imagine like, you know, you have, let's say, a SQL database or any type of database, right?
我放在一台旧笔记本电脑上，我最近把它拿了出来，我下载了客户端，迁移了我的钱包，然后不得不等待，你知道，很多……我想大概是一两天，当我的计算机基本上下载了区块链的整个状态并快进，以确保没有交易……所以有一笔从匿名互联网陌生人到我这里，五年前、六年前的交易，并且在区块链中在那之后没有任何交易，我的 0.05 比特币被发送到其他地方。没错，没错。所以想象一下，你知道，你有，比如说，一个 SQL 数据库或任何类型的数据库，对吧？
You're going to put commands on that database. You're going to say, like, insert a row, you know, alter this column, you know, insert this new row, you know, delete this row. And just think of all these, like, SQL commands, right? Now, imagine if you kept a history of all the commands you gave this database ever. Well, then you could recreate the database, right? It's probably not the most efficient way but but it works right if you took all the commands you ever sent to your database and you ran all those same commands on another database you would end up with the same data on both right hopefully unless there's like a rand or something um um but uh so so so that's basically what's happening is everyone's getting all the commands
你要在那个数据库上放置命令。你要说，比如，插入一行，你知道，更改这一列，你知道，插入这一新行，你知道，删除这一行。只要想想所有这些，比如，SQL 命令，对吧？现在，想象一下，如果你保留了你曾经给这个数据库的所有命令的历史记录。嗯，那么你就可以重建数据库，对吧？这可能不是最有效的方法，但……但它有效，对吧？如果你把你曾经发送给数据库的所有命令都拿出来，并且你在另一个数据库上运行所有这些相同的命令，你最终会在两者上得到相同的数据，对吧？希望如此，除非有类似随机数之类的东西……嗯……嗯……但……所以……所以这就是基本上正在发生的事情，每个人都在获取所有的命令
such that when they finished, they all have exactly the same database. And that database has everything. Like it has how much money everybody has at any given time. That's right. Um, as everything. It's, it's a ledger, right? Where, I mean, maybe ledger isn't a commonly known term anymore, but I mean, it's, so when I say that someone sent me some Bitcoin, unlike actual, you know,
这样当他们完成时，他们都有完全相同的数据库。而那个数据库拥有所有东西。就像它拥有每个人在任何给定时间有多少钱。没错。嗯，作为所有东西。它……它是一个分类账，对吧？在那里，我的意思是，也许分类账不再是一个广为人知的术语，但我的意思是，它是……所以当我提到有人给我发了一些比特币时，不像实际的，你知道，
dollars, where if I say Jason gave me a dollar, then I typically mean he took a printed physical piece of paper with a unique serial number and gave it to me. When I say someone gave if if I were to give, you know, point one Bitcoin to Jason, I don't actually give him a cryptographic hash or anything. I don't I'm not transacting with him a unique something. What I'm doing is sending a message into the globally replicated ledger, this running account, this log, as Jason was describing. I'm saying there, hey, at some point, my account has been tabulated to have one whole Bitcoin, maybe because of mining, maybe because somebody sent me something, because I did something, a service for them or whatever.
美元，如果我说杰森给了我一美元，那么我通常是指他拿了一张印制的、带有唯一序列号的物理纸币并给了我。当我提到有人给……如果……如果我要给，你知道，0.1 比特币给杰森，我实际上并没有给他一个加密哈希或任何东西。我不是在与他交易一个独特的东西。我所做的是向全球复制的分类账发送一条消息，这个运行中的账户，这个日志，正如杰森所描述的那样。我是在说，嘿，在某个时候，我的账户被计算为拥有一整个比特币，也许是因为挖矿，也许是因为有人给我发了什么，因为我为他们做了什么，一项服务或什么的。
And I want to send, you know, whatever I said previously, I've forgotten my example. I want to send however many worth of my Bitcoin I want to now send to Jason's address. But I don't actually nothing goes to him. Just now the ledger reflects that now he has some of the money that i had previously so my account sort of says minus 0.1 bitcoin and jason's account says plus one bitcoin and that's recorded in the ledger globally in this replicated state right and so when patrick does that so because everyone has everything the only thing everyone doesn't have is all the private keys of course right but everyone has everything else right so so patrick signs it with his private key um he encrypts it and he
而我想发送，你知道，无论我之前说了什么，我已经忘记了我的例子。我想发送我价值多少的比特币，我现在想发送到杰森的地址。但我实际上……什么都没有给他。只是现在分类账反映出他现在拥有我之前拥有的一些钱，所以我的账户显示减去 0.1 比特币，而杰森的账户显示加上 0.1 比特币，这在全球范围内在这个复制的状态中记录在分类账中，对吧？所以当帕特里克这样做时，因为每个人都有所有东西，每个人唯一没有的就是所有的私钥，当然，对吧？但每个人都有其他所有东西，对吧？所以……所以帕特里克用他的私钥签署它，嗯，他加密它，然后
encrypts you know the message and then also some some some way to to verify that um it's been uh to some way that we're when you decrypt it you know that you've decrypted it correctly right i forgot what that's called um but some set of bits there right some magic bits. Then that message goes out to everybody and it spreads like virally like everyone just starts sending it to each other and then everyone starts using their Patrick's public key to decrypt his message and read it. And so the decrypted message will say something like, give Jason a dollar or give Jason a Bitcoin, but it'll also have some way to verify that it was decrypted correctly, right? Because what you wouldn't want is someone to encrypt it incorrectly. And when you decrypt it, it says, give someone a million dollars and you just do it, right?
他加密，你知道，消息，然后还有一些……一些……某种方式来验证它……它已经被……以某种方式，当我们解密它时，你知道你已经正确地解密了它，对吧？我忘了那叫什么了……但那里有一组位，对吧？一些魔法位。然后那条消息发送给所有人，它像病毒一样传播，就像每个人都开始互相发送它，然后每个人都开始使用帕特里克的公钥来解密他的消息并阅读它。所以解密后的消息会说类似，给杰森一美元或给杰森一个比特币，但它也会有一些方式来验证它是否被正确解密，对吧？因为你不想有人错误地加密它。当你解密它时，它说，给某人一百万美元，而你只是照做了，对吧？
So there's some secret key, some secret set of bits that have to be encrypted a certain way. Um, so if people get it, they decrypt it and it seems legit, they apply it, right? If they decrypt it and it's just total garbage, then they reject. They say like, we're not accepting this, this, this like a transaction. We're not accepting this transaction. We're not accepting this message. And then at that point, it's kind of like a democracy. So, you know, it happens extremely quickly. And if you've signed it correctly, a ton of people are accepting it.
所以有一些密钥，一些必须以某种方式加密的秘密位集。嗯，所以如果人们得到了它，他们解密它，它看起来是合法的，他们就应用它，对吧？如果他们解密它，它只是完全的垃圾，那么他们就拒绝。他们说，比如，我们不接受这个，这个，这个……像一个交易。我们不接受这个交易。我们不接受这条消息。然后在那个时候，它有点像民主。所以，你知道，它发生得非常快。如果你已经正确签署了它，一大堆人正在接受它。
And in the opposite case, a ton of people are rejecting it. And so in that way, it sort of heals itself. Oh, go ahead. I was going to say, just as a sort of side topic, you were talking about databases working that way it sort of heals itself so along oh go ahead i'm sorry i was gonna say just as sort of side topic um you were talking about databases working that way um actually a whole class of modern databases do work that way they're called log replicated storage um and so cool they actually do work by essentially record and it's a way to distribute to other people for exactly those reasons that what the current state of the database is and so you sort of send out a proposed change as a log and then once other people confirm they've received that then you actually reflect that in your current state and there's ways of compacting
而在相反的情况下，一大堆人正在拒绝它。通过这种方式，它会自我修复。哦，你继续。我本来想说，作为一个侧面话题，你谈到数据库以那种方式工作，它会自我修复，所以沿着……哦，你继续，对不起。我本来想说，作为一个侧面话题，嗯，你谈到数据库以那种方式工作，嗯，实际上有一整类现代数据库确实以那种方式工作，它们被称为日志复制存储，所以很酷，它们实际上确实通过本质上记录来工作，这是一种为了完全那些原因而分发给其他人的方式，即数据库的当前状态是什么，所以你发送出一个提议的更改作为日志，然后一旦其他人确认他们已经收到该日志，那么你实际上在你的当前状态中反映这一点，并且有压缩的方法
the log so you don't have to keep the whole transactional history anyways it's a side topic but if you're interested you can look it up yeah log replicated databases um so so yeah there's this question of like what happens if i try to be really clever and i say um i go to two different machines and i say uh you know uh give this other account that i also own a dollar from this other account. Like I have account A and account B. And I go on two different machines and I say, hey, A gave B a dollar. And I do it both at the same time.
日志，所以你不必保留整个交易历史。无论如何，这是一个侧面话题，但如果你感兴趣，你可以查一下。是的，日志复制数据库。所以……所以是的，这里有一个问题，比如如果我试图变得非常聪明，我说，嗯，我去两台不同的机器，我说，嗯，你知道，从这个其他账户给我也拥有的这个其他账户一美元。就像我有账户 A 和账户 B。我去两台不同的机器，我说，嘿，A 给 B 一美元。而且我同时做这两件事。
And in this way, I think I can somehow double my money. Well, that's not going to happen. What's going to happen is, and Patrick, if you could correct me on this, but basically there's going to be some type of master election process. So a bunch of computers are going to get the first command, a bunch of computers are going to get the second command. There's going to be some kind of banter back and forth. But at the end of the day, there's some kind of Byzantine resolution system
通过这种方式，我想我可以以某种方式使我的钱翻倍。嗯，那不会发生。将会发生的是，帕特里克，如果你能纠正我这一点，但基本上会有某种主选举过程。所以一堆计算机将获得第一个命令，一堆计算机将获得第二个命令。会有某种来回的玩笑。但归根结底，有某种拜占庭式的解决方案系统
that's going to eventually, it's like an unstable equilibrium, that's going to eventually cause one of those two transactions to fail um and uh and that's that's basically the gist of how that works so it's there's a lot of good things there's also a lot of kind of uh bad and ugly parts of uh of bitcoin so i mean yeah everyone hears this like the silk road was famous it's what it's called yeah the silk road um and you know just ways of sort of extorting people for money moving the money around uh and then if you can find you know like i said it's once you try to convert to something physical there's sort of an end point but this is a common criminal thing like this is always true if you steal money you need some way of sort of an endpoint. But this is a common criminal thing. Like, this is always true.
最终会……这就像一个不稳定的平衡，最终会导致那两个交易中的一个失败。嗯，而且……而且这基本上就是它是如何工作的要点。所以有很多好的东西，也有很多……比特币的坏和丑陋的部分。所以我的意思是，是的，每个人都听说过这个，比如丝绸之路很有名，这就是它的名字，对吧？是的，丝绸之路。而且，你知道，只是勒索人们钱财、转移钱财的方式……然后如果你能找到，你知道，就像我说的，一旦你试图转换成实物，就有一个终点，但这是一种常见的犯罪行为，就像这总是真的，如果你偷了钱，你需要某种方式……
If you steal money, you need some way of sort of spending the money without being noticed and being able to move the money around without being tracked. Or else people can figure out that you committed some crime. You know, they can put two and two together. And Bitcoin, it's not my opinion that it really, the pseonymous thing is is sort of useful there but it isn't like this is fundamentally going to ruin the fbi or whatever investigative agency you have in your country like it's not going to ruin their ability to find criminals um it does facilitate you know sort of along with some other technologies it can make it harder but it doesn't seem to me as long as
如果你偷了钱，你需要某种方式在不被注意的情况下花掉这笔钱，并且能够在不被追踪的情况下转移这笔钱。否则人们就能发现你犯了某种罪。你知道，他们可以把二加二放在一起。而比特币，并不是我的观点，它真的……假名的事情在那里确实是有用的，但它并不是说这从根本上会毁掉 FBI 或你所在国家的任何调查机构，就像它不会毁掉他们寻找罪犯的能力一样……它确实促进了，你知道，某种程度上，连同一些其他技术，它可以让事情变得更难，但对我来说，只要
if people end up if they can't live their whole life you know solely on digital goods and services then you know eventually they'll try to spend the money and you can catch them at that point yeah i mean it does require like an international effort it can yeah um and so and i think it's just that the i think what will happen is that more businesses that do goods and services in bitcoin will probably get more regulation that they already have on dollars and i don't but i don't think that's a bad thing for bitcoin that's just a sign that you know sort of bitcoin is growing up or ethereum is growing up like all of these will begin to be regulated. And right now it's just, it's a sort of temporary loophole is I guess what I see.
如果人们最终……如果他们不能完全靠数字商品和服务生活，那么你知道，最终他们会试图花掉这笔钱，你可以在那个时候抓住他们。是的，我的意思是，它确实需要像国际努力一样，它可以。嗯，所以……而且我认为这只是……我认为将会发生的是，更多在比特币中做商品和服务的企业可能会得到比他们已经在美元上拥有的更多监管，而且我……但我认为这对比特币来说不是坏事，这只是一个迹象，你知道，比特币正在成长，或者以太坊正在成长，所有这些都将开始受到监管。而现在它只是，它是一个临时的漏洞，我想这就是我所看到的。
I don't long-term, you know, it's not a big deal. The same thing like, you know, in the U S gambling is illegal. And so there's a threat. If I send dollars to,
我不认为长期来看，你知道，这不是什么大不了的事。同样的事情，就像，你知道，在美国赌博是非法的。所以有一个威胁。如果我把美元发送到，
I don't know where the, you know, online gambling sites are, but some, some other country, then somehow when I get dollars back, that gets recorded and I have to sort of explain where it came from.
我不知道，你知道，在线赌博网站在哪里，但一些……其他国家，那么当我有美元回来时，那会被记录下来，我必须解释它来自哪里。
But if I sort of send it in Bitcoin, do some transactions and get the Bitcoin back, like no one has to know that those Bitcoins that I got back were from gambling winnings. And so it's actually, you know, in some ways it's easier to convert it back to US currency. But again, same thing as I said before. I think eventually the regulations will sort of catch up on this more.
但如果我以比特币形式发送它，做一些交易并把比特币拿回来，就像没有人必须知道我拿回来的那些比特币是来自赌博赢来的。所以它实际上，你知道，在某些方面更容易把它转换回美国货币。但同样，就像我之前说的那样。我认为最终法规会赶上这一点。
It just seems like a continuous thing on the Internet, that cat and mouse game. So yeah, it'll probably make things harder, but don't do bad things. You'll get caught. Yeah, exactly. So this technology in and of itself is really amazing. And one thing that's kind of amazing is Ethereum in particular created this thing called the Ethereum Virtual Machine.
这看起来就像互联网上的一件持续的事情，那场猫捉老鼠的游戏。所以是的，它可能会让事情变得更难，但不要做坏事。你会被抓住的。是的，没错。所以这项技术本身真的很神奇。而且有一件事很神奇，以太坊特别创造了这个叫做以太坊虚拟机的东西。
And basically, you can use the Ethereum messaging platform and all of that to do other things like for example um you could make your own uh set of currency like let's say for example i want uh um what's i'm trying to get like a good example for this like uh let's say i want to do some type of votes so um i want to go and people can do a certain amount of work. They can get one of these tokens and they can use that token to give it to different accounts. And each account represents voting for a different person. So you can kind of do pseudonymous voting. You could do all sorts of donations and fundraising and all of that.
基本上，你可以使用以太坊消息平台和所有这些来做其他事情，比如例如，嗯，你可以制作你自己的……一套货币，比如，例如，我想要……嗯……我正在尝试得到一个好的例子，比如……比如，我想做某种投票，所以……我想去，人们可以做一定数量的工作。他们可以得到这些代币之一，他们可以使用该代币把它给不同的账户。每个账户代表为不同的人投票。所以你可以做某种假名投票。你可以做各种捐赠和筹款等等。
That's a little bit more direct application um in other words you could set up little credits and people can exchange uh you know bitcoin or let's say ether for for these credits and then in in exchange you're going to look at whoever has those credits and give them like some part of your company or some some like yeah this is how the you'll get something back this is how the dao i don't a dow i don't and that's how you're supposed to say because this sounds like dow jones but the dao and ethereum was supposed to work you sent money to the dao and they gave you a dao token which was different than the ethereum you sent but it allowed you to cast votes like you got a unique
那是一个更直接的应用……换句话说，你可以设置小额信用，人们可以交换……你知道比特币，或者说以太币，换取这些信用，然后作为交换，你要看看谁拥有这些信用，并给他们，比如你公司的一部分，或者一些……比如，是的，这就是你将得到回报的方式，这就是 DAO……我不……一个 DAO，我不……而且这就是你应该说的，因为这听起来像道琼斯，但 DAO 和以太坊应该是这样工作的，你把钱发送给 DAO，他们给你一个 DAO 代币，这与你发送的以太坊不同，但它允许你投票，就像你得到了一个独特的
token based on how much you contributed and then they would put up measures for voting and the system would count how many unique tokens it saw for any given measure to decide if it passed or failed right yep um so yeah it's it's it's pretty amazing it's pretty early on um also ethereum is totally open source i don't know about bitcoin if it's open source or not yes it is okay yeah so so you could like uh especially if you're on a company like if you're doing this enterprise you could install your own fork of ethereum on all your machines and then you could use it for like an anonymous message board like complain about your boss and you can't know it's you or something i don't know um but you could could set up a blockchain and have sort of pseudonymous, you know, voting
基于你贡献了多少的代币，然后他们会提出投票措施，系统会计算它为任何给定措施看到了多少独特的代币，以决定它是通过还是失败，对吧？是的。嗯……所以是的，它……它非常神奇，它还处于非常早期的阶段……而且以太坊是完全开源的，我不知道比特币是否是开源的。是的，它是。好的。是的……所以你可以……特别是如果你在一家公司，比如如果你在做这个企业，你可以在你所有的机器上安装你自己的以太坊分叉，然后你可以把它用于类似匿名留言板的东西，比如抱怨你的老板，而你不能知道是你，或者什么的，我不知道……但你可以设置一个区块链并进行某种假名，你知道，投票。
and messaging and things like that, which is kind of cool. So I expect a lot of cool things to come out of this technology. And that's probably a good point to sort of wrap it up. So I want to make one thing. I said log replicated search storage but that if you are going to go search on it's log structured um databases sorry log structured yeah if you search up the other thing no results come up it's log structured oh cool log structured storage yeah i've never even heard of this all right um well till next time have a good one. This is a bit of a long episode, but we had a lot of cool stuff to talk about with this. It's super interesting. It's hard to wrap your head around, but I think it's amazing. And hopefully you guys could bear with our 90 minute show or however long it's going to be.
以及消息传递之类的东西，这真的很酷。所以我期待这项技术能带来很多很棒的东西。这大概也是结束本期节目的好时机。我想纠正一件事。我刚才说了日志复制搜索存储，但如果你去搜索的话，应该是日志结构化数据库，抱歉，是日志结构化，对，如果你搜索另一个词是搜不到结果的，是日志结构化存储，哦酷，日志结构化存储，我以前甚至都没听说过这个，好吧，那下次再见，祝大家过得愉快。这期节目有点长，但我们有很多很酷的内容要聊。这真的非常有趣。虽然很难理解，但我认为它很棒。希望大家能耐心听完我们这期90分钟或者更长的节目。
Thanks a lot for all of your support. Thanks for liking our posts on on all the different social media uh and thanks for your emails uh we've gotten some really good suggestions we'll definitely take advantage of that um and and and cover them in future episodes so uh have a good one the intro music is axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢大家的支持。感谢大家在各种社交媒体上点赞我们的帖子，也感谢大家的来信，我们收到了一些非常好的建议，我们一定会采纳并在以后的节目中讨论，所以，祝大家过得愉快。片头音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下发布的。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传播本作品，也可以进行重混和改编，但必须注明我和Patrick的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。